[Music]
[Music]
all right what's going on
realm around what's going on talk to me
talk to me
sick slayer what's going on how does it
the geeky nerd shows no elite
nine lives two ten
what's going on you already know first
of all i got super shout out i gotta
shoot by um
master master clowns x three you'll turn
out super chat paying my respects and
admiration to the lord that's much love
much love bounty boom what's going on
make sure my levels are good make sure
my levels are good we got adequate
building
what's going on slim 73 what's up keonta
what's going on
talk to him at it what's going on you
guys let me know that's her attic good
he's awake he's fresh man why are you
everywhere i think
one week
super panda let me know if y'all can
hear us how are we doing
make sure the level is good for a kid
get in here and blow spot
which will be very soon talk to me chat
27 of y'all in there what's going on
just nine toes
what's going on somebody let me know if
my levels are
good obs is acting weird today
thank you sled much much appreciate
that's all i needed yeah i heard attic
good make sure y'all heard
it good too
we should get the king room all right
thank you [ __ ] now so look like they
sound both of us good already
but um yeah we'll be rocking and rolling
rand has responded and he will be
in here soon you know what i mean oh
probably okay if i destiny here this
week uh cross play
ah yeah you gotta wait like 90 days bro
that's that's yeah
rockstar nobody thank you other zinc
thank you thank you
all right so we're just gonna chill out
we're gonna king should be arriving soon
rand will be arriving soon and of course
the sastradamus so you already what's
going on that's some faces what's up
so we gonna see you out a bit y'all
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
yo yo shout out to master clowns x3
29 super chat lord cognito you hopping
back on console when the series x hits
for sure destiny 4k 60 silky frames oh
yeah you already know
yeah uh me and me and coming back
you know coming back we're coming back
we're coming to see red
it's pretty much like the it's pretty
much be ascending from the havoc
exactly coming down materializing
because like what people don't tell you
about the heavens in these video game
streets is this pc [ __ ] be breaking down
too much buddy yo we gonna be we got a
mute shot because uh king won't come
back in and we're gonna get a copyright
strike
yeah you better hurry for music right
now now talk to y'all a minute y'all
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
this
[Music]
ah
[Music]
oh man all
we are live
welcome to the ilo's podcast and the
lords of gaming.net
episode number 168. it's another
glorious sunday we're back at the round
table on the lord's day
i'm very excited about our special guest
and we've got the xbox game showcase
aftermath and spider-man miles morales
to discuss
so we gonna get right into it i want to
introduce a lord who has not only been a
solid friend and supporter of the realm
but is truly one of the top five content
creators of all time
whether it be his battles perspective or
brutal honesty in regards to the games
industry
you can always count on this lord for
his consistency
and top-notch analysis introducing
the creator and host of the random thor
youtube channel and co-host of the xbox
2 podcast
the legendary man with the million
gamer score and the leader of the
anti-film
games movement live
from the south side of the shop and
making his triumphant return
into the realm of the lords my man
lord randolph thor how are you doing bad
your intros get better
every time then anti-film movement
100 the truth give me get those 30
frames
i was hoping jess could make a shout out
to jess i know you had things going on
but i literally when you two go at it
with that
i think it's the funniest thing i
literally pull like i listen to you guys
in the car and i pull over the car and i
laugh
so the worst thing about it is he's
being dead seriously
it's not like a joke he's like no i'd
rather i really be at 30 frames i'm like
what is wrong with you
he's created a movement with and i love
the disgust that you have towards it
so it just it's great banter man but
what's going on bro it's been a long
time to have you to realm
how you been you know been a while i
know um
you know it's uh you know it's going
okay you know the uh
we had the xbox show on what was it
thursday now feels like it's
already like a while back but uh you
know
there's a lot there to talk about some
new games were announced
unfortunately with cgi trailers a
that's when you own your bs you know
shut out the entanglement
but over there what have you been
playing sir uh i've been uh
trying to get through ghost of tsushima
whoa
i just made it to the second island and
uh i dig the game
uh quite a bit uh the open world stuff
like i did everything on the first
island right
like did all the find all the question
marks did all the
side missions liberated everything
i've been trying to pull myself from my
fun games on game pass to play that
tire you know what i realized because i
was watching people stream about that
i realized how much of a beast i was at
at that game because
everyone's health bar is like three
times more than mine they played without
doing it
like no house springs i'm sitting there
like
look at me oh you you guys girl
is that the winner is it you have one
more i got one more after that
okay let me get gamers played ten
dollars super chat two things g4 is
coming back in 2021 is a big deal that's
kind of true number two rebuilding xbox
nation through positive vibes great
gaming
and look forward to the great streaming
and captures that we bring
hashtag game on players so let me get to
dddt
dt taylor find out super chat thanks to
my dude king david for
shaming my tcl i'm a proud owner of a
okay king is out here with motivation
right there
i want everybody in the realm to put
that crest up from my mind
blow the horn
that's a big that's a big move so you
pcl dudes take note
take note he's gotta know he's future
gaming now he's gotta start coming at
the high sense dude's king
oh no yeah i'm not even questioning
you better not look me in my eyes back
back to red
oh so yeah so you clear it out the map
you do your thing yeah yeah yeah
but like with every open world game
eventually i just kind of get uh
fatigued
yes with all the uh extra stuff so i
think probably going forward from island
to and beyond i'm just going to focus on
playing doing all the missions yeah you
know it's a great world to explore it's
very beautiful
uh but i mean this happens to me in all
open world games i just reach a point
where i'm just like you know what
i just kind of want to do the missions
and that's pretty much it i don't want
to
ride around looking for little foxtons
you know
they're kind of useless fallout 3 in
fallout new vegas is like
permanently fatiguing on open world so i
always just do the main story now
so that's pretty much it sir yeah for
the most part you know i
i had some back issues last weekend so
yeah um
but uh ghost ghost sushima's really good
so
and i don't know what what is what's
coming out next man once you finish this
game i'm trying to think of the game
oh my god is dead they once and done
something
oh well let's get to you sir there's
nothing that thing
that excites you for the future as far
as uh within this generation after
ghosts yeah i mean like i'm just trying
to think of the next game
that's coming out is it is it uh
avengers in september is there
is there something i'm missing in august
a good point tell me why it comes out in
august
i'm grounded
i think i'm actually going to try that
out with dizzy he's convinced
he's like dizzy's the ambassador yeah
ready for that yeah
he bends the needle to my obsidian it is
oh shout out to porsche powers yo shout
out to the big cavs he was one of those
guys
last night oh my god they really did it
up for us shout out to aisli shout out
today and the whole crew he says tony
hawk september 4th right does that
excite you i'm not really never with you
oh not really not really okay not really
i mean the next game i'm really looking
forward to is probably
what do we have in september man like
mark avengers doesn't look very good
uh no it's it's a good it's it looks
very good
i'm not buying anything but it didn't
cover the game so i
chat just let us know what you think oh
out of worlds expansion word word yes
so we will get into the show a lot to
talk about and you already know we got
the four horsemen of gaming those
originals of the realm here at the round
table
debuting our new speedier five-minute
intros
my co-host with the co-host my brother
from another mother the difficult game
conqueror
lord of reviews and the how of the young
wolf my man lord addict how we doing sir
doing pretty good man uh you know after
that event yesterday it's uh
it's been a time on twitter man it's
been a time yeah
it's been you've had a lot of fun on
twitter
yeah definitely have man i definitely
have people people
friday on twitter man people frauding on
twitter but
we'll get into that later no doubt
salute to you representing aeronautics
with the follow-up super chat the lord
should stream playing grounded for
charity
interesting hey a rademus hit me up in
dms uh you have a gift coming to you
yes yes yes yes though the bank always
plays its debt so it's off tells you
that make sure you get your reward that
you want
and of course we have our most technical
gaming lord the single player solo gamer
lives with a single player selfish
experience
and also the software i'm sorry i'm
sorry solve a bunch of your intro
because i'm gonna right cg miller has
been on the floor he says two dollar
super chat i'm only here for gangster
addict i
will spit out my juice and i know what
he's talking about that's what made me
realize so
apologies to solve for your intro
and also testosterone
mr offline profile illuminati and little
patriot of the iron bank
my man with a completed intro hello
how are we doing you're doing pretty
good doing pretty good awesome
excited to talk about these topics today
you know um
what i've been playing uh that
when i'm home that's taking up my time
you know how i know that's a good you
know how i know that's a good game
i'm playing it again oh wow okay
yeah i'm enjoying that's the only thing
you can do with playstation games
bubble up do a plus mode do plus move
over
stuff just plus you left the cherry
blossoms
the game is just i had to stop taking
pictures because it's like
everywhere you get how people always be
on that picture stuff
like i know that game is crazy beautiful
like for nobody
i was about the king addict right there
but i don't believe i'm alone
i guess i'll just i don't know none of
that
when i play a game i want to play a game
i want to spend 40 minutes trying to
find the right angle to take a picture
that's my guy i don't i don't go into
photo mode and
spin around i don't do any of that i
just take the picture where i'm standing
like
like like a nice vista or something
that's it i'm not going into there going
into filters and no none of that
okay but i was having fun that combat
like i'm opening up that skill tree and
like
all the combat stuff you guys you you
guys know me like
when it comes to samurai like
mitsurugi i think of you like you used
to tear us up in solo camera
with
he still has he has the disrespect when
he kills somebody when he just
puts his back to him and then she's the
katana again
one where you hold him in five minutes
oh my god
that's true we're getting low he's right
tom ki so anyway real quick um besides
that i played uh
carrion carrion is freaking me
you know look at him interesting it is
so
good that game was dope it passed five
minutes
and of course we have randy's loving
this we have the incredible hulk of this
aka the access gamer oh the lord of
combat sports
king of the statues who demands nothing
less than that premium experience
and is the leader of the fraud alert
movement
oh beloved lord king how are we doing
sir
yes let me see that miles now
what's going on all right well um go to
lawsongaming.net to
see mount morales to get all the
dimensions and everything new kos
is up yes um return this
this week i've been struggling trying to
play go to sushima
because game pass has definitely been
hitting me with those
bangers and now i'm not gonna lie
they may not be uh what people call
triple a games and i and i'm starting to
struggle with that stuff because addict
has
really fodders kid well he he's he's
told me
attic told me what's a triple a game and
i guess
it means to that person okay so neon
abyss has definitely got me
just crazy and then i put on carry-on
boy if you ever want a venom or or
carnage in your life or a blob it is
the wildest game going i put it on it
was amazing
and also playing cross code so there's
so many games in there that i'm jumping
from and doing stuff and trying to get a
board done or something done here and
there
to move forward and then i run over to
go to sashima
uh try to do something there and that's
it
but that's all i'm doing that's what's
up that's what's up man but yeah for a
carrier very good you got
some coverage out on launchgaming.net so
please check that out
can i ask you a question bro what do you
what do you say to the people that uh
say you're just surrounded by a bunch of
dolls
oh you you're the reason this is going
five more minutes
hold up before we start picking g2 super
chat here for the halo slander
and
this is what he's here for so when you
see miles morales back there coursing
more than people's playstation 5.
when you see a ninja turtle over here
costing more than
some people's pcs because you know
they'd be out here with the bs
when you see a deadpool that caught
quarters some people keeping me in the
millions up right now
a master chief over there that cost more
than uh some people's car note
about we have teletoy that's right over
here on the side
that costs more than some people rent
um and you got a thanos over here that
costs more than some people mortgage
but they try
all your kids school clothes this year
for all your kids school clothes too so
without meeting your kids going to
school naked
but the face of the check is flexing
right over there i got superman over
there what they do
is the way you had to say why you had to
be like shut your tco
well he had to shut his mouth up why was
he talking to me like
i love it i love it i love it oh my god
it was classic red i i
normally i do not get involved i was
very tempted to click like on that all
right
i normally i got it out of it now you
know what was crazy you guys seen it
what's that when when when bill still
will like
yeah bill still kicked out oh my god it
was on the statue joy it was a statue
thing
and i was like that is my guy today got
it that joke was like sixth grade right
there
thank you rand for breaking this back up
is people rent the shipping is seven
hundred dollars
man if you don't get away from me so
you've heard it here first gamers do not
bother kig
with your tcls and a little budget
gaming because king will come for you on
twitter that's just what he's
follow me anyway and of course
i'll get there before i get my trigger
dude errol channel with the five pound
super cat
i rushed out of work to listen to you
guys representing uk
gamers london halo infinite demo loved
it
will look great when released no doubt
we're gonna get to it big up london uk i
got fam over there you already know and
of course we got the gaming ninja
himself
the shinobi the tsushima shinobi
represents red that realness of the
rubber iop not telling what you want to
hear but what you need to
hear so yeah just a little bit of
destiny not really much cause i've done
everything i need to do i got my battle
score thing 100 i just tuned in on
tuesdays until
everything's until beyond light right
now i got everything i pretty much
needed
so i'm rocking with that you already
know i've been on that ghost
hard body karate you know what i'm
saying so i just did uh two more legends
and um i mean i found two more legends
right so i'm working on those cards
those are my favorite quests in the game
when they do the legend of the samurai
and you gotta find out his mystical
thing and then you follow the clues
and you know what i'm saying you
following purple flowers into a mountain
and
all this craziness but yeah i really man
i just love that game and yes i am the
guy who does the photo modes i get look
for the best pictures
but me and my best dance is my best
folks yeah at least at least you're
playing the game and
the game is definitely too so i think i
think the only time i brought a photo
that's the wrong button on accident is
just happy i am not playing this i'll
tell you yeah but i don't play wrestling
i'm productive man you'll be back though
november 10th
new expansion maybe series x will be out
by that or maybe it'll be out soon after
60 frames
you're going to get off the pc and come
back yeah
no more no more pc stuff right i'm
coming home baby i'm covered
and you're going to be there with me
yeah you're going to be excuse me you're
going to be in there now you're going to
be shoulder to shoulder
destiny up get your titan out we're
going to be
load up the 25 minute intro let's keep
it going
last week's results are in the people
have spoken to the question with the
pressure of the xbox game show cast
showcase approaching for microsoft which
of these games do you feel should start
the opening of this show this was
controversial at the time
the winner of the four-way ilp pro at 47
percent
was halo infinite set the tone with the
console for fps legend
coming in that second at 23 of the vote
was brand new ip
third place at 20 percent of the vote
was fable prove it exists
and that last place at nomination of the
vote was i don't care if best not be
grounded or sea of thieves
shout out to all of y'all it was a lot
of y'all on this man but i got to give
it up to my boy right now
dude i got to give it up to the wolf the
young man got it he got it got this he
stood on his square he
fought ainsley off the evil aims lee the
evil luke law
was there any doubt look at that
look how he pulled up on the side back
you look at that look let me see that
give me that talk give me that talk was
it anything any doubt that i was gonna
be wrong
if you listen if you listen to me last
week
you could definitely like i wasn't
speaking if
i was speaking when right
he wasn't wavering at all that's true
he's like yo don't you dude he was
waving
at the end of that conference he said i
don't hear this
he had six minutes left his kneecap was
knocking yes
he he he he took his attempted stride
you know it dizzy yeah dizzy you took a
l2 sir yes that was you too
but um get clutch man two hours
man these five-minute intros have me
rolling time
rand has told me he pulled me to the
side he said [ __ ] i love your show
but damn it it's too low so we're all
right it is 123 right now we're about to
get in the first topic all right
that's amazing normally it would be in
hours look how many times
about getting into the first topic let's
get into it all right we was literally
about to spend 15 minutes bragging about
spending money
it wasn't me it was it was king came in
here it was like i gotta go
i gotta go i gotta go we ain't doing no
four-hour shows
so it is arrived the game show aftermath
the show that we'd always do normally
after e3
and uh this time because there is no e3
we got to rely on these random shows and
we had the xbox games
showcase so the lords have now had time
we did the live reaction you know what
we felt live at the time but we've had
some time
to sit on this a little bit go back and
do all this stuff so let's get right
into it now i want to do a little
different
only i want you to talk about your whole
thing on the show but
not halo infinite yet we're going to
save halo infinite
that's because if we start talking about
halo we talk about anything anything
else because halo is its own
beast so lord ryan you've been making
the rounds it's like a world tour for
you sir like you've been making it
it's every everybody's hitting me up man
like you want to come on the show and
it's like oh yeah sure why not you know
absolutely we must hear your opinions
so now that you've had more time this
year what are you thinking what are your
thoughts
um um you know
i still like the show i didn't think the
show was great by any stretch of the
imagination
um i didn't think it was horrible either
let some people say but hey everyone's
entitled to their opinion you know
if you loved it you loved it if you
hated it you hated it i'm not really
going to argue with anybody about it
just don't send me your stuff
keep on getting people keep on telling
me oh so-and-so feels this way about i'm
like
i don't care what so-and-so feels
um for me whatever what i've been
very vocal about in the past on my own
shows my videos and other people's
podcasts was i always wanted microsoft
to
kind of open the door and let people
know what they're working on for games
down the road
right that was been my thing because you
could make an argument that like oh you
actually didn't know what xbox was
making it was always like well if you
it was all just gears is coming or
whatever which is which is fine gears is
great but it's like i always like
let me in on the secret show tell me
what you're you're making in two to
three years right
and they did that so that's what it is
what notice rand that people that's that
some people that's all they wanted
they're like i just want to know these
games are developed
we know faye was a development just tell
me that's all i need
that is true so i yeah so going in there
and and hearing the announcement from
hey vaude's comment from obsidian it
looks like it's a skyrim game just like
what i've been saying for like the past
year uh you know state of the k3's
coming which i hope they can hit the
levels of that you know uh trailer
because uh that's definitely a step up
if they can
i have my doubts but we'll see fable
being announced is great
so i just wanted them you know you
bought all these studios in 2018 you
promise you're investing
in xbox it was about time to be like hey
this is what we're working on
and you know we didn't get to see
everything because we didn't get to see
what the initiative's working on or what
the compulsion's doing or what
inactive's next project is or any of
that stuff
but i did what i wanted they showed me
the games that are
in development uh that'll be coming out
in a couple years
the only real issue is i think they did
it in a way that
wasn't very satisfying basically
basically they just give you a trailer
about fable that was a minute long that
was cg so you get really
no you get really no like view about
what
fable really is it was just like it was
just here's the game
you don't know anything about it
whatever here's about uh it's a minute
long
it's whatever and i i kind of wished it
was a little bit longer like if the
train
was like two minutes long like i would
imagine like fable it's like yeah it's
cool to know it's coming but
man i really would it really have killed
you to show me like hey why don't we
fly into the city and like see some
people walking around get it like a
i gotta push backwards of what
fable is rather than just that
announcement trailer so
um yeah that's that's kind of where i'm
at like i wish they didn't show
like tell me why or like
grounded or you know like outer world
dlc i feel like those could have just
been held off
like like outside the main event
um the ori 2 thing was kind of weird uh
it was like oh we're patching it for
xbox series x which is cool
120 you know 120 frames non-filmic
not filming oh great but then i sit
there and i'm like but then later on
after the show you also announced that
forza horizon 4 and gears and gears
tactics and
see thieves are getting updated so like
why did it wasn't or you just include
ori in that one too and you could have
had something with the new game
right well yeah i don't know like and
then hellblade which probably the
biggest disappointment for me
you know they show up and they're like
hey guys we announced how blade
all right see you later yeah like you
you're telling me
you're not giving me any any news
you're not showing me anything new like
you're just going to be you know what
that kind of felt like it kind of felt
like they cut something out of there at
the last
minute and threw something out like it
kind of reminds me
it kind of reminds me back when that e3
was sony where days gone was randomly at
the end like it was and people
assumed that something was snatched out
of there too because remember they
showed days gone twice in one conference
yeah it kind of gives me that impression
that it's like yo
uh was something happened it was like
you know called this
thing company right now they don't have
nothing make something oh
okay you got that youtube thing right
yeah bring that bring that that's
i think i think a lot of stuff that
you're complaining about
is uh back rubbing from microsoft to a
lot of these developers
like obsidian obsidian showing um the
dlc
um that's them telling them you know
good job
you know um we're gonna showcase and we
also know that we
it led it led into their big game well
no that
i'm a little bit more forgiving of the
right worlds i think grounded thing
because it led
into that my biggest thing was basically
i wanted to see more of about and fable
how many times do people say stupid
things like well
um nintendo puts up a jpeg and the world
goes bananas
and you know it's like they're damned if
they do
they damn yeah but i don't know but i
don't care about nintendo's i don't talk
about it literally
a png of metroid like people with crazy
years ago it feels
crazy and we haven't seen nothing about
this game since then
let me ask you this what do you i mean i
i i hear what king is saying i i want to
pose it
back to red in the sense of it's kind of
a touch
tough situation because we've kind of
gotten on them i feel
that they never give us that future of
what they're doing right
and they only talk about right now did
they give us a little bit of what they
do it and we still got to upset because
we like we want to know more so it's
like
so i get what you're saying no rain like
you say it says like i i do i did feel
the the fable thing cut right when i was
right at my highest interest level
after the frog eaten and i was just like
okay cool
but then part of me does understand like
okay how much can you show because which
we'll talk about in the next topic
you know when you're showing things that
may not
necessarily may not be ready you know
the internet is very
quick to pick it apart so what what do
you feel about that thought process for
the developers
it's it's it's not so much that like
it's basically that it was cgi right
and the about thing i think maybe stuff
at the end like and a lot you know even
the warhammer dark tide and the stalker
stuff
these are great announcements and
they're probably going to be cool games
it was just
it was just i just don't i don't know
maybe it's my old age now
but i'm looking grateful they didn't
share any of those gameplays
you know i've been through countless e3s
with you know cgi trailers
or demos that looked way better than the
actual product that we ended up getting
i've been through this before and it's
just really hard for me to get
truly excited about something that isn't
probably going to look like that more
than likely right right so
i don't like those things rather so let
me ask i'm gonna bring this to all
everybody rob
do we rat again i come from the vertical
slice era so i'm used to it like
but my thing is do we rather not get
any cg trailer yeah no because let's say
let's say legitimately it is not ready
to be shown and they don't have
an engine ready but they want you know
so you just don't tell the bait like i'm
just trying i'm trying to be honest
what i see is they show the logo at the
end right
yeah well just show the logo and be like
bigger better better now all right so
you want you
rather the dev come out i'd rather you
save the money
you know what i mean somebody putting
together all this cgi crap for no reason
that probably won't be utilized at any
point in time
and it's not going to be representative
of any game
so why even mislead anybody in any form
or fashion just
show the title of the game right if you
don't have anything to show
we're working on this bigger better
better see us then
solve and what do you think about that i
think if you are going to do the cgi
thing
i think you give me you give me a two
minute trailer though they really give
me an idea
of what what i'm saying is that that way
you really give me an idea of
tone you give me like with fable you got
the idea that the tone is still gonna be
comedic right then you have this fairy
and at the end she gets eaten that's
that's
fable down to a t that's fable right um
but i definitely would have if you're
gonna go that route go all the way if
not i agree with king don't do it don't
spend the money
um and yo give me a flyover or something
at this point this is the thing though
at this point you
they have to have something right there
i'm not saying about gameplay i'm not
saying what if it's not
what if we we look and then we see oh
you know what
give me the game tell me about the game
five years in advance i just want to
know you're doing something
right turismo up and people was clowning
the lighting popping in the tunnel
like you know it's it is it is one of
those things where
i i just think when it comes to
microsoft yeah
they don't have the good will to
necessarily get away with that
it's just that's what it is like when
playstation does it people like are fine
with it because we know that
we know great this is coming up right
yes the assumption is there the cache is
there with microsoft
it was it's imperative on them to to
force
that issue be like no this is what our
games look like you have to
you have to step it up and i like it
when they put in game
engine if you're gonna do that don't
give me no cgi
crap okay okay in game engine i'm good
fan enough back to ran i wanted you to
finish your thought
with this whole debate as far as the you
know the cgi
showing too much it's my own it's my
personal opinion i just don't care for
cgi stuff
like i'm with king if it was in game and
game engine like what
blade was or whatever enough i wouldn't
care if it was a minute or a minute and
a half i just
it's like state of decay 3 trailer like
am i supposed to believe that's state of
the case
and then the thing is the thing is when
you when you think about what state of
decay is right
unless they have some ridiculous like
like unless they're twelve teraflops off
it's called
unless they're turning it around
completely that game looks nothing like
that yeah you know you believe in the
variable rate shaded
you able to believe it's all it's gonna
look like that day date
what's the other thing like um people
like now people's expectations for state
of decay 3 are right
basically like look like that and if
they can get anywhere close to that
it'll be an amazing achievement
but you know who knows who knows when
that game's coming it could be
2023 at this point i i also
really i do enjoy the like i really like
the fact that microsoft is giving their
developers
a long period of time to make this
because
people people people want like xbox be
like well you need to give your
developers freedom for
to make what you want it's like xbox is
doing that and if you want
them to make a great game you really
can't turn it over quickly right right
so they talk about these studios like
obsidian and ninja theory
and uh like playground and all this
stuff and
what it looks like just judging from you
know the the trailers they put out with
no dates like fable had note eight and a
vowel had no date
you could probably make the assumption
we are looking at 20 22
at the earlier enough yeah so like if
fable was in development in
late 2017 early 2018 by the time it
comes out it's be three or four years
development same thing with the vowed
you know their microsoft is giving the
teams time to make the game
to the vision that they want with the
production values that they will have
right and like my my thing's always been
with xbox is like i don't care what you
make
as long as what you make is great but do
that
you have to give people time to create
right and
and you can tell like okay would it be
great if these games were coming at
launch or in
their next year yeah probably but would
have been as good
if they weren't you know if they were
released or you know if a vowed was a
two-year project instead of
potentially a four-year project oh yeah
oh yeah like so
so to that point rand uh besides them
giving them the time to do it
what do you feel about a lot a lot of
these studios having multiple teams
working on different projects rather
than all focusing on
one big project i love that yeah i mean
i'm fine i'm fine with multiple i'm fine
with multiple teams within a studio like
grounded what like 10 people right
uh you know uh obsid uh the
avowed is probably the the majority of
them and
uh some of them are probably working on
outer worlds dlc and right
imagine eventually they'll kick up a
team to start doing outer worlds too
right and uh you know ninja theory has
got hey there's a team that
bleeding edge which is really small but
the majority of the team is working on
hellblade 2.
they got problems another part of them
working on project mara
i like i actually really like it when
when teams when when devs have like or
studios have multiple teams really i
like it too right
i like it have multiple teams and
they're able to do multiple things
man i would love to see coalition do
gears and something else at the same
time
right i i feel that that works for
microsoft
because of the way they're positioning
their self
they need that type of uh machine
they need that type of split up
multitasking type of thing
yeah whereas sony needs to like zero and
naughty door i don't want naughty dog
splitting up into four different groups
um
game pass that's not how i hold up i'm
getting at it
i know i'm tired of you trying to act
like you put words in my mouth i never
said that right teams being split up on
my
team no i've never said that you're the
one that keeps saying i don't know who
they
are let's go dude let's go
what have you said sir my stance has
always been i don't mind if they're
making on multiple games i just want
them to make on the games that they make
i don't wanna
but just make the same type of game or
three teams well it's not they make this
thing
not the game obsidian has made multiple
games
that has all to do with rpgs so they've
made stuff like this
but that's what they do i don't know
i'm just clarifying your thoughts they
make something else
okay we're gonna make something else
let's make something like ground let's
make a survival game
i don't want that like you you can't you
can't have it in both ways
you can't get a man we don't want that
but no i'm not talking to you
i said people can't get mad we won't
need your theory to make
multiple projects they make leading edge
i don't want that
i actually like it
i like horizon zero dawn if if you don't
allow these companies to exactly
grow and be what they're supposed to be
we'll never see what they're capable of
right but
my point is this and we'll put this
little tiff to bed for being at it
is that the thing is i'm trying to put
it to bed you're the one ain't putting
the bed
i mean people keep every time i come on
the show every time people come on the
show they keep talking about this
oh
i absolutely do so to put it to bed like
i was saying
for me one thing i said that i love
is when you look at a team like um
what's your guys
uh that did uh kill zone and then
horizontally
gorilla games right i think that's a
beautiful thing
because that is a team that historically
was known just for killzone and those
type of games
and then they were allowed to try
something
else now i feel y'all on the passion
project little stuff
hold on let me get my balls off
get your thought off sir thank you so
like i was saying
my whole thing is what i think is a
beautiful thing
is when they are allowed to try
something
that is on a bigger scale of a triple a
scale right and is completely different
from what they're used to
you know what i'm saying because they
want to do it and to me horizon zero
dawn is a great
example of that i think that's a
beautiful thing that's all i'm saying
especially if the team size red
is big right if it's a smaller team i
get it focus
on what you need to focus on is what i'm
saying but
if you are playground size i think it's
dope playground is making fables
like i think it is yeah
let's get this yeah we got slow-mo with
the two dollars
hopefully a vows combat is better than
skyrim yes i hope so as well
shout out to stubs gaming with the one
pound super chat police say something
sir
right and then we have stubs again with
the two pound super chat i love to tell
the tell me why trailer great show guys
how long we have we got we got jumped a
little bit then we have cj
cj miller again two dollars super chat
cog be careful gangster at it takes no
prison
yeah we're good all right cool so before
i get to attic i want to ask rand one
thing um
just in reference to that point with the
um the this dude do you understand why
i'm kind of going i
ordered okay again i mean people also
like look at lisa's my opinions like
if you don't agree with me that's fine
we're cool like it doesn't matter
yeah like this is just what i think like
i'm like i'm still like you know what
i still feel really good about what xbox
is doing
um i i they showed me the games that
they're working on in the future
even though they're you know years away
which is kind of what i thought
i mean the people ask me like oh did you
really like this show and i always say
yeah and they're like well how could you
i'm like
well because i literally told you guys
what the show was gonna be on monday
right put out my preview video go back
and watch it
i had every game from first party there
even stated the k3 was like
halo's gonna start the show fable's
gonna end the show
forza is gonna be there you know state
of the k3 is gonna be there
uh obsidian's i even said it was a city
and skyrim pillar spin-off game was
going to be there yeah i literally laid
out the entire first party
so because it was exactly what i
expected it to be right
i enjoyed it for what it was could it
have been better yeah every show could
have been better
like every show that people could put on
could be better and i you know if they
had used
in-game engine stuff instead of cgi
trailers i probably would have rated
this higher
um i think a lot of people now kind of
look at it like
the thing about this is like is that
these games are
are later right it's just halo infinite
yeah
right away and then these other games
are
essentially a couple years from now like
none of them really had dates
right and i'm a selfish person
right i'm very selfish i like seeing
that these games are just coming to
series x and pc
no xbox one you know what i mean
because i know i know that's kind of
getting to that i know that's a big
talking
like phil saying you won't you we won't
but it's like i knew that was going to
happen
i knew it was like at some point they
were going to be like listen these games
aren't going to come to xbox one
right and yeah like all right
these games being so far away yeah
they're not going to be on xbox one so
talk about it rick because i'm glad you
brought it up i but just about the
pounds
but i got we got to talk about it which
is all right a lot of
twitter right shout out to hogan he's
got an amazing
video up virtual legality on this and um
the issue comes down to messaging right
and
what he is saying and what a lot of
other people are saying who are
vehemently
upset about what we're talking about
right now is that
when phil came out and made the address
and said
um look we're not doing what playstation
is doing basically essentially right
patients say we believe in generations
right they said look
we believe that if you have what you're
in our ecosystem
right you rock with us you take your
stuff
forward right now we watch the show
and yes halo infinite does count right
we know that's going in
you know both whatever whatever but we
watch the state of decay trailer
we watch in a violent trailer we watch
certain trailers and at the end
you see xbox series x and windows 10.
you don't see xbox one now red i'm with
you
selfishly i don't mind it but from a
messaging standpoint when you just told
the base you
market it to the heavens that we are
about
bringing everyone together kumbaya bring
your xbox sad
and live your best life and then
they watch the trailer the xbox sad guys
and say
yo it don't say xbox one here
so can you at least understand that
thing that people are upset saying that
they
kind of messed up with messaging again
or do you think people
are overreacting and well you just want
your series x games to
highlight i think it's a little both
they said a couple years right
uh you know going into 2022 is a couple
years
these games are all essentially 20 22
and beyond
so i mean like they're telling the truth
because that's what it's coming out
but it's just like yeah it really just
seemed like it really just seemed like
we're not gonna force people to upgrade
for halo and that was
that was pretty much it i mean it looked
like laughing
because you're laughing it's literally
semantics
it's literally it's the biggest switch
no it's not a baiting switch it's not a
bait and switch we you are not getting
this games these holiday seasons
they're not technically that's what
we're doing when they do come out
it's gonna fall in exactly what i say
from this
date i say in a couple of years from now
or a year or two and he said a year or
two
um we're gonna hold your hand but then
we're gonna let you go
all right so your hands have been let go
so that game that you saw
that you said oh my god i can't wait to
play that upgrade
my mind is this if if that is the case
right and if you think about
the cadence of the release of these
games and win these games we we assumed
these
these studios started whatever you could
have assumed that that was going to be
the case
now the question is was it worth it for
them to come out with that narrative
exactly in in in
kind of in response to playstation's
narrative yeah
if it wasn't even really going to be a
thing
hey playstation do it all the time
because
the thing is
but the thing is who would naysay right
would they say against this type of of
of
ideology moving forward you put yourself
in a position where people already
dogging you for for this decision that
ultimately doesn't
matter in the long
500 by the rallies it's a 500 pay wall
sir
i mean come on man they know they know
for a fact if they don't drop with it
let's okay if you had this holiday
season
and they gave you the the the holiday
season coming to playstation 4 and
playstation 5.
miles morales dlc for the playstation 4
if you already have it and playstation 5
a whole new game
it's the same game with the eight hours
uh are you gonna pay 500
fair enough at this business it's busy
that's probably better
but from an ethical standpoint i don't
care about that
not even not even from the ethical
standpoint i think because
because playstation was able to turn
that narrative around be like no we
believe in brand new things right it
just makes you look
worse than you no it looks fantastic
because
it looks fantastic cause fall at least
two to three weeks before the real
before the skirt came up dudes was like
yo
we still get to play our joi we still
get to play our joy and then the show
came it was like
i literally looked at the screen i was
like oh it don't say xbox one
and i ain't saying you didn't hear me
say a word but then i looked at it and
said oh that game ain't coming out until
later anyway
so he's right he about right yeah
infinite grounded you're going to get to
play the dlc for outer worlds
and and hold that and hold that okay you
know what
let me ask you a question how would you
feel if they would have said that out of
worlds
dlc is a new game
that's actually a good one that's
actually a good how would you feel
so so so what what's the name of the
underworld dlc um something to gorgonzo
so that's a good one so if the they say
out of worlds dlc
gorgon is a separate new game remastered
and it's going to be only available on
the series x that's
okay
the xbox has no games debate
people got a year and a half to upgrade
no excuses all right
then we have gamers play 5 super chat i
don't care that a majority of games
aren't coming xbox one consoles remember
they gave today they gave debs the
options the devs gave the answer
moveon.com and
then we have dan rodriguez
this is like strawberries and cream
chocolate and peanut butter
figs newtons rand and the lords coming
together to deliver that sweet gaming
good
this weekend keeps delivering shout out
to the season
i mean when it comes to that whole thing
like we we can't sit here and act like
that
that's not an issue like i get it people
don't think selling a standalone dlc
that's like equivalent to what um you
know a lot of people don't
like xcom in the chat i'm sure but what
x-com did
is they had uh x-con enemy uh unknown
that was the base game
and on pc you could buy enemy within but
on console you had to buy the whole game
again
right so not only are the but
at least they were on the same console
like sony's literally
saying yo you guys like this spider-man
spider-man hot
in order to play the next one that's a
stand-alone
there's probably fi that's probably 10
hours long we're going gonna make you
buy a whole new car
i get that but let let's get back
focused no you're right i i mean i know
where you're going with that i should
say
what i want to ask you though which was
the initial thing
which of people were saying yo you know
phil and the guys they were saying bro
you know
you know stay with us you go forward
like what do you feel about that addie
like
is the isn't that a mystic record you
like die it's the same thing over you
know
you don't you don't feel that way it's
mixed message these people don't listen
like microsoft's always had the you know
the the worrying that it's not it that's
what they're going off at the beginning
right that's the only time it matters is
at the beginning of a generation
that's why i said they said up until
like a year year and a half you know
we're only going to have
games on both but these the games that
they showed at this conference
it's it's not mixed messaging the games
that showed at this conference
besides maybe forza and we don't know
anything about forza i mean he kind of
acted like it was in
in midge generation early production or
early production so
this game is clearly going to be another
one of those games that happens after
that
he these games are being referred to the
ones after that they said
is the is the time point so it's just
like we can't see here
what you know obviously not everyone on
this panel but we can't be like
yo we we want to see these games man you
know
uh we we just you know how many people i
saw that's on facebook
that's on twitter when i read facebook
but twitter that's like
i just want to see what a roadmap that's
the problem with microsoft
you know we see so much from sony for
years ahead we know what we're getting
and
then microsoft does it it's like why we
get no gameplay
stuff that's going to be happening in
the game okay for instance state of
decay we've never
had any form of wild animal life
that trailer showed you you know uh that
we just want to show you that the game
is in development which everyone pretty
much knew that it's like and you'll be
able to fight wild animals
okay so so i'm okay with that fable
people one of the biggest questions
people had
is it gonna have that humor in it that
cgic
showed it's going to have that humor in
it but you know
in the game engine thing i i don't think
that was a nest
i don't think that was possible for
those games we might not even know if
those games have an engine right now
like they have to go what they have to
guard do we think what was
what was the bigger evil them coming to
this conference of no fable
or did they come to the conference what
they showed on facebook
i feel that part i feel that like i said
no i i can't get down on that king
because
like what's the difference between
showing a sword and the fairy gets ate
by the frog and then just showing the
logo
i don't know how much that was really a
couple of million dollars
i don't know how much to see but i don't
think
that and you can roll it into marketing
but i can
i feel that that money is better used
someplace else right you know you can
you would have been happy if he stood up
and showed you a logo and said
and we're doing fable you've been like
yes
right my thing is them spending that
money
right people know what's going on in
favor i'm sure they don't know the whole
concept
there's not going to be a bunch of
questions and have somebody draw it on a
piece of paper
you know sometimes they do little
artworks you know this is the
i've never bothered you with the
interruption so
i mean i understand sometimes you may
feel attacked
attacked is an automatic can't say
anything right
man well it's just at the end of the day
like
you know people gonna have to accept it
it's just like look they don't have
stuff to show you on some of these games
uh people can't scream for the top of
the hills we just want to see
announcements and then when they show
announcements
we just want to see game play it's like
it's it's crazy the amount of deflecting
that i'm seeing going on about this
it only happens with microsoft it really
does like it truly
only does because at the end of the day
might sony be showing you games
six years in advance and no one bats an
eye
all right but now it's like it's not
okay
they get songs they've proven to uh
announce games five years out and the
games come out but
if there's something that gets canceled
but it's not it's more than that
it's more than that let me jump in it's
it's it's that
it's the promise the hope of the future
but the thing is cache will always be
given when the promise is delivered
right when the promise is delivered you
saw um
god of war for the first time and
whenever long it took come out and last
of us two for the first time however
long it took up
but when it came out it was a quality
game
so the base is going to say look i'm
willing to wait
because at least i pretty confident that
these are going to be bangers
whereas microsoft they had the first
party issues over the years
they not afforded the cache because we
saw a lot of these metacritics
wasn't as high as what it is so i i get
what y'all saying with the double
standard thing i'm not saying it's fair
i'm just saying the mindset is what it
is you know what i'm saying that that's
what it is
but we got to get the super chat get
ready we got to get the super chat store
there we go
we got mark laprad la friday or with the
final super chat all these playstation
dudes playing checkers microsoft and
phil spencer plays chess
game pass checkmate um when we have brat
with the five dollar super chat the best
thing to come out of xbox game showcase
was the brute meme aka craig
lord messi salute very messy very nice
and we were caught up
all right so we come up here we have two
we got two more oh get up
please he said it twice yeah he said it
twice
it's like i said like look everyone just
wanted
a road map and you know when you go back
to talking about you know
the the amount of benefit that sony has
for making these games
they were getting these before these
games came out right well back in 2014
when they announced
i don't know if it was 14. it's one of
the earlier e3s when the announcement's
coming out the next five years no one
said anything like that
right people were just like we know
what's coming out and i think that's
what people want it's not necessarily
i don't think they had that kind of
cruelty back then you know
i think they had the last of us but at
that time let's be real here
sony wasn't popping out a banger every
week in the beginning of the gym
people still didn't doubt them people
still getting talking about 2016
you're talking about 2016 when they
showed off god of war and they shut off
days gone and they shut off spider-man
yeah
you talk about that yeah and no one said
you know what how long are these games
coming out
like no trust me attic people were
definitely like
spider-man's not coming out for four
years when they came out two years later
but the same thing with god award like
oh god awards not coming out for another
three years and it came out two years
later
just my issue with everyone is it's like
yo you cannot
ask for for for a map like people kept
saying
phil you need to break your two-year
thing you need to break your team
and then when he does it we have no game
play to show we have not
like you can't have it both ways and
that he is right from the standpoint of
i'm
i'm interrupted i admit hey i've been
cognitive interrupted
that um what you call it that this scale
bound thing addict remember
he they were so he was so they were so
burnt by that that he got
negative feedback and then he went into
a i always say he went into a shell but
they kind of went to a show as far as we
don't want to show anything that's not
whack the game was whack man
i saw the the jittery mess that it was
the frames was horrible
it was garbage it was hot trash and
these people are still to this day
talking about little scale bound it was
it was cancer you wasn't buying it
anyway
it was trash the thing the thing when it
comes to about this
is like look i i was more interested in
a road map than anything else i wanted
to see
what i was looking forward to and when
it comes to you know
i don't even think i think people are
taking
the first 15 minutes of the show and
trying to deem the rest of the show off
of what they saw the first 15 minutes
it's almost a perfect segue continue
it's just like you know obsidian
i don't know if anyone in here knows but
upset i didn't know i've never played
pillar i love rpgs but those type of
rpgs i try to stay away from because
they're consuming
you know yeah uh-oh he's
nope he's doing his biting a little bit
a little bit you're biting
uh we don't hate anymore up he's gone
hopefully we get him back
i mean what you got red finish your
thought before we uh move on because i
definitely want to transition
uh i don't even what was the original
sorry
the original thought was just about
again announcing games early
and the mixed messaging possibly of the
cross-generational stuff
i mean the the messaging i mean the
cross-generational stuff is just the pr
battle between sony and microsoft that's
all it is
sony's is saying they believe in
generations
and all that stuff because precisely
because xbox
isn't doing uh you know xbox series
x only stuff for the first couple years
so they they highlight that as the
strength of their console
and xbox sees it you know because
they're not doing it they
say we're not gonna you know lock you
behind we're not going to force you to
upgrade and they see that as a uh
you know as a strength i've always
talked about pr is always about
you know playing up to your strengths
and downplaying your weaknesses facts
and that's what they're just both doing
it doesn't really mean anything it's
just it's just a pr battle between two
companies trying to sell you a product
this year
but it always was going to end up at
some point
it was just going to be series x games
right and they said
you know a couple years it just so
happens that
the games that are going to be on xbox
one are going to be halo
and whatever comes out in 2021 right and
then whatever else all their studios are
working on for later
right we're all going to be series x
exclusives
yeah now you know could you have not
have said that
probably but it's a pr battle it's it's
like sony's saying that you got to say
something back
you know so it's just it's just kind of
the way it is hpr
spr and remember we're only talking
about first party stuff right if you
think about
how they how they um fill up game pass
right
the vast majority isn't first party
stuff right these are deals they have
with smaller
indie devs with third-party devs to get
their games on there
um i think it's it's attractive to these
people to to
sign on the game pass knowing that their
game will be available
for you know uh generations of machines
rather than oh we're locking your game
to
the brand new console that nobody's
bought yet right so i think
the game pass narrative i think the game
pass narrative sort of
is why that that sort of
cross-generational thing makes more
sense
for xbox even if it doesn't necessarily
apply to the first party stuff right
that and not that anybody i don't know
maybe
people do care about the fact that they
can keep their old console and play
you know devolvers you know next two
games for the next five years they can
play it on their x or they can play it
on their s or whatever the case may be
but i i think the you know that part of
game pass how they populate game pass
in in large part is with those type of
games right so
i i think in that regard they're not
lying to us like you you'll still be
able to play those games well
i mean this this show is basically uh a
presentation for a game pass
right it wasn't really even a
presentation about why you get
why you should get serious x because
nothing was even shown on series x
comes out afterwards halo infinites on
pc even the
gameplay footage of crossfire x was on
pc right so
it wasn't a show but we could argue the
merits of like well you didn't really do
a good job of
selling people series x the show which i
don't agree with but so
we can transition right into the halo
backlash
i mean let me just finish let me just
finish my thought um
the the thing is like eventually
microsoft is going to put xcloud
on the older devices eventually so if
you can't upgrade
and fables out and let's say fable is
series x only which it probably
is what it's going to be uh then fable
fable you could essentially stream x cl
you could stream fable on your console
through xcloud now i know you know
internet and all that stuff isn't
you know everybody's kind of spotty with
that but i'm like that's the plan
they're going to put xcloud on the older
consoles
right for you to play those games if you
want to and then if you need to upgrade
then you know you need to get lockhart
which is going to be
you know pretty cheap 299 250 you know
series x there'll be options there or
the pc
depending on where you where you're at
you know so the games will be there to
play it's just
you know it you won't have to upgrade
right away
right you don't have to upgrade until
2022 uh
for these games so you got some time i
mean look at people
the way the economy is going to be
everything's going on right now not
everybody's got money to spend on new
consoles so
it's like okay i get it um but this is
kind of what i've always
expected them to do it's like yeah these
brand new games we're building they're
going to be on
like how cowboy 2 is not going to be
natively on the xbox one s
or the xbox one you know so it's just
kind of what it is
fair enough so i finished without as far
as your impressions
i don't know what happened there no
that's good after after solve goes i
want to finish my
dog let me get these super chats first
we have everborn saga with the two
dollar super chat they said one to two
years
if fiam the rip i don't know what that
means
then we have rap again two dollar super
chat i say this the medium looks like oh
from the rip from the rip they said one
or two years from the rip
oh my god from the rip he threw some
hood in there
then we have a bra super chat i'll say
this the medium looks awesome
yes it does um then we have brap again
with the two dollar super chat i might
have jumped
a bunch yeah okay then we haven't played
the fight on super chat yeah i can tell
you what happened after the xbox game
student
showcase new fans of halo and the future
game pass subs and japan's support is
bigger
you gotta got a 25 24 24.99 super chat
for women hood
game pass for the win that's definitely
a fact but we got a five dollar super
chat from couch gaming
i like the show but it seems that the
overwhelming segment of social media is
negative
does microsoft have to do something to
flip that before launch
uh just just show game passes the games
that's all they got to do
uh got a 10 shipping chat from brat
regarding game pass it presents an
interested consumer is tremendous
amount of value it could be also uh
present microsoft an opportunity to
create
marketing deals with third party for day
and day on
game pass i don't think that's happening
i think they use
game pass as an opportunity to get some
of these marketing deals but
i don't think they can use mark game
passes like something to
leverage getting the market he tells
himself we got a five dollar super chat
for pixel
g xbox is clear one to two year support
but with no
games announced you'd be a fool to think
that that was a lot of games
folks mad no uh no held back they're
interested
interested that is what so solve your
thoughts now you've had time to sit on
it
you know i still uh again my strongest
feelings were about halo and how they
chose to
show that and i guess we'll get into
that in a second but beyond that i still
i still feel like again the honestly it
feels like
their next gen secret sauce is game pass
like
really just the fact that you can't look
at that
lineup of games and know that again they
they finally did announce all this stuff
that's further down the pipeline that
we're
hoping are our exemplary games
um and to know that stuff is coming in
the game pass is exciting it just it
just
is like if you don't have to be you
don't have to be in love with
microsoft's ecosystem
you just have to be in love with not you
know emptying your pockets and
it's just game passes it is kind of
bonkers what
they've done um specifically the stuff
that they showed yeah
um i again the smaller games look great
even some of the stuff that they showed
in the pre-show
i think you know people who are looking
for banjo-like games and stuff like that
there were a couple of games there that
looked interesting
right um and to watch everything again
in 4k
right now that was absolutely necessary
to see someone like for me we'll get
into the halo thing
it highlighted some stuff in halo that i
i i didn't like
but beyond that watching the entire
presentation in 4k
gave me a better idea of what these
games look like what they run like
um and it's again it has me excited
because i get to try all of this stuff
that if it was on another platform and
without this type of service
i'm just i'm not even going to look that
way i'm not even looked at but let me
let me let me counter you one quickly
also
what about to the people who say oh so
we cool with
accepted lower standard of quality
because
in the the answers it is it is on
microsoft to change that narrative and
they they have not done the greatest job
in doing that right when
when game pass launched and then we got
state of decay 2 that was essentially
broken right we got crackdown which was
which was what it was right right
listen i played through all of i loved
crackdown
let's keep if i ran i don't want to talk
about crazy
but you know what i mean like um it
wasn't until it wasn't until for the
horizon for launch that people were like
okay
we we we got a true triple a high
quality game
right that we could we could have
expected that from from playground and
forza horizon right
and and it's in game pass and it's the
first time people were like okay
let's see what the rest of their lineup
looks like moving forward then we got
the outer worlds which was you know it
it's
fine it's not like the super high super
high polished game
but it it's a good game that's right
it's a good game
so it's a matter of and again we'll get
into the halo thing it's
gear 5 already i want i for me for me
for what i want from x
i want xbox selfishly selfishly i want
them to give me
games that on every level production
value wise
stand shoulder to shoulder with some of
sony's best
okay and i don't i don't know that we're
gonna get that like i just don't
know do you not know because of gamepads
well again you can get it we don't know
the details of how game pass works in
terms monetarily
and what that means what what i can say
is and and it went
to the point i was talking to you was
talking rant about the multiple teams
right
if that is the case right that these
multiple teams are are smaller teams
allowed to work on different things
and the quality of the end products is
not up to what we consider to be
a part to what the the competition is
doing right
do you then say hey maybe we need to
consolidate these teams to work on a big
budget thing
to stand toe-to-toe with these other
things right it doesn't behoove us to do
that
if the quality of the end product isn't
up to snuff
right to get out of it you got to really
do something yesterday
to be honest with you like i think we'll
get some
games instead of the quality of sony's
big one but to be on
like that's another one of the issues
when you break up teams into smaller
entities is
there's less people working on every
game for instance you know
naughty dog they might work on multiple
games
but they they rarely work on multiple
games at the same time
and if they do it's always a small
portion of people while they're
finishing up a project
right so you know that's one of the
reasons that their games have so much
qualities because they got
like a crazy amount of people working on
the game it's like
and i do and i do think that you know
their talent speaks for itself too they
have a lot of good talent
obviously microsoft has been snatching
some of that talent right so i mean
if you look at it from the standpoint
you know i was going over all the
metacritic scores for every single
student they had yesterday because i'm
making a video
and i was like the only even double
fight has
crazy 85s and aboves right
it's like the only studio that really
has to prove themselves in terms
of what they can make is the compulsion
and undead that's literally all
right you know obsidian has has made
almost every game they've made it's been
an 85 and above almost
every game they've made i get that city
was the biggest deal for them that's why
that's what i said
ninja theory i didn't know this those
devils no those devil may cry games they
scored well i didn't know that but they
scored like 85
so i get it and everything you're saying
is valid i want you to get the super
chat but the only point up the counter
they're going to people are going to say
and the stigma is like well
as soon as xbox signed them we gotta see
right
because they're gonna say we need to see
that same level of quality
underneath this banner so that they can
so we can dispel this whole thought
notion
that microsoft controls we're not going
to stop doubting my man
and that's my question right now i'm
listening to all this rhetoric man i'm
listening to
all y'all doubting my man like this man
has literally
put microsoft on his damn back
when you saw the july show what he said
and it gonna be like that may show
was it no it was probably the best
pacing they've ever had
so this man has literally
staked his whole career on yanking all
these little verbiages out of your mouth
so when you're sitting and saying i
don't know if this team is going to
deliver
i don't know he over there making sure
they deliver
yo listen that game ain't coming out
until that game looked good if it don't
look good i
wanted to beat xyz here gamer i mean if
he's hearing you
okay okay so question so if hey if halo
if halo ain't ready
is he he's gonna hold it he's gonna put
you back he said he would um
so that game will come out of it right
but the winning talk about halo right
now let's get back to this game pass
real quick
because it was a gaming pass show all
right so this game passed
everybody been saying game pass didn't
put none but father inside there well
i'm sorry bro pass is rocking right now
oh i don't know how game pass is going
to make any money
well 15 million people know
at what point in time you're going to
sit here and stop people really idiots
when they keep saying that
care about oh how much cashew sony got
it's not about them right now it's about
the fact that this
y'all keep on doubting the same
individual how many times does barry
bonds got to go up to the plate and
knock it home run out the ball
before you get that for you yeah
let me ask you a question you know just
to clarify for
for the chat let me ask you a question
if game pass isn't making money would
microsoft keep
keep investing in game pass
clearly they're making money for do you
think well that's the argument not even
worth having with people
do you think 10 million people are
playing a dollar for game pass 50
million people is out here and it's
y'all got to stop you got to leave those
numbers
this is the same thing that they was
doing before xbox
uh uh one stayed on 50 million for four
years
ain't still no more consoles yeah i've
literally said that multiple times
people literally take remember no it's a
35 million for
like five years because they're not at
10 million if they do a goddamn whole
show about it
there's a whole show about it you know
going
the rest of this year right if you buy a
series x
right you don't have to spend another
nickel out of your pocket
right i'm good this is it right here and
let's just say
you don't have it financially right you
got that
15 a month right you went there like
swimwear right
and you say that at the other side of
the base i don't think so
it's fair enough okay i want to let you
get your balls but we saw this right we
gotta get you some chats
all right cool let's get the super chat
then i'll get mines in there so adam you
gotta read this one from wilming
yes i don't even have the screen up
right now all right uh you got it
got us off yeah i got it uh will me with
the 50 dollar super chat just wanted
addict to read another one
yeah yeah he wanted you to read that you
can get to oh i see will me getting
getting debo mode now
i couldn't read that one but you know
you're more than welcome to do another
one oh my god
i'll read that one with me i'll read
that one scrub nursery
super chat will the 4k showcase look
good on the tcl
much love to the panel and and the
biggest fact of the showcase all those
games playable on game pass yeah that
cannot be denied then we had insipid
ghosts
acknowledging multiple arguments thank
you that's what i do absolutely
let me rebrand we got a five dollar
super chat from brat
gay pass is like the 109 and all you can
eat sushi buffet
look looks okay but a little bit of
stuff
is uh noodle premium new food
i'm not i'm not talking nobody you doing
and what's funny brad is uh let me ask
you a question brad
do you have game pass no what i want to
ask brad is where was you when the heat
was on your neck
[Laughter]
hiding in the closet like the whole time
and the moment he could say something
he just kicks that door out
i don't see you another one oh yeah okay
we gotta find out the super chat from
will me
wonder what fills patreon to your prices
get a tattoo on his chest
look man look i'm pretty sure that um
i'm pretty sure that phil got good money
so he ain't trying to have no patreon
you like probably leaving his house
right now unless he had to go to japan
carrie wood got curry how he got
something for king man
15 for a bunch of free to play games is
not a deal king
okay well i hear what you're saying but
i understand that you can't maintain a
subscription service so you're afraid of
it
i understand that the fear of you dude
you know ecl dudes because you sound
like you got a tcl my god
i hate
i'm sick and tired of you dudes afraid
of game pass and i understand why
because you are afraid that when you
can't pay that bill you can't play no
game yo
yo that's what it is that's what a low
key is
100 factor because i hear you guys talk
about but i own my stuff
that's this you only got one cd bro
so i'm playing 200 games you know why i
love game pass so much
i have absolutely zero fear of losing my
king are you implying that the reason
they're afraid of
is the fear of not maintaining 15
are you implying that i mean to me to be
honest with you he
that he's true it's true because people
say well you i like
owning it because if i don't have game
pass i still have
when they go to log in they get that
denied button
y'all foul i can't with y'all y'all
doing too much you're doing the most
you're doing the most
yeah okay so i gotta go we got two two
uh two more super sets we got michael
aka besides finest two dollar two
after the 723 shows game passes on
everybody's mind
most of the haters complaining on
twitter already
carrie howard again with the two hour
super attack you're not the only with
the only one with the back i make 7k
clown
he makes 7k clown how much you put it
there how much you said
you say all type of dumb numbers post
[ __ ] up boy
oh this is real millions talk this is
not about payroll i don't know you want
to get into this conversation
so be careful this is this is your whole
check all right we gotta stop we gotta
start
because there's a lot of millions talk
this is above our pay grade we don't
want to do it
then we got it and we got who happened
over here will be hood with the final
super chat
t-cells now offering a monthly payment
plan that's why they can't get game five
shout out to jade over the show to us
carry out 70k as much bro all right
let's chill with the personal attacks
y'all
move on we going left we don't want it
to go too late before
we're not checking i don't want it to go
two left y'all we having fun but not too
loud look i'll make it quick
because i got to get my bars off and we
move on to the actual bait event when i
know everybody want a hairball
look we watch the show like you said
soft 4k
you know again everything i'm not gonna
talk about halo we'll say that next
but my score remains the same man i
still like i told red i still have it it
is an eight out of ten and um
the thing is this look i get it if if
those games didn't appeal to you
i look at it bro i have 13 games that
i'm excited for
13 games bro so for me i'm looking at
the joint like
dragon quest i'mma switch guys so dragon
quest is huge
coming to the switch
you said switch guy no i said i see you
guys
i said xbox was a better place without
dragon quest uh no i heard
i was so disgusted i was listening to
xbox two so bad and then
whatever what happened now whatever what
are we wrong with about
no no no the xbox is a better place than
our dragon quest yeah yeah all right
cause enders oh yo i was so riding
i so wish jess gord was here because i
was so right he he was disgusted how i
was discussing with you i was like red
he doesn't realize the importance of
this jj rpg the biggest
and you know what the funny thing about
that is
you know how many people i i wouldn't
watch a lot of reactions you know many
people don't even know that didn't come
to xbox
like the moment i saw that i just turned
off their
stream immediately it's just like you
don't you you don't keep up with the
xbox ecosystem you want to make so much
criticism about the xbox ecosystem
but you don't even know dragon quest
didn't come to you
because my thing is let the millions of
people who love
this franchise it's an iconic franchise
go
play this game and they know they can
get it over there but here you know i
was joking i know i know but you you
were throwing it on thing
but i said it like deadpan
i don't give a [ __ ] it was so good man
you got me
you gotta be my feelings man it's a big
deal for dragon question
yeah because that is one of the only
rpgs that's
never been on the next level that is
that is like that is the most japanese
thing the most japanese man
let's look at that song of iron look
fire kind of gave me wolver blade vibes
you know what i'm saying a little viking
side school of very bombastic
exo mecca bro like i don't even
like battle roy i was like what is this
like transformers with the dino bots
they had a dude looking like silver
surfer on the surfboard
i'm in i am in on that of course
of decay 3 i'm a fan at the end of the
day randy's right it is cgi
it's not gonna look like that but to
addict's point
it is a representation for the state of
decay fans we know they don't never have
animals in their game now we got the
zeds possessed that's going to add a new
different dynamic
shout out to undead labs who we've had
on iop before
we were very upset in the sense of like
yo how y'all got the tethering issues
are y'all not using
azure servers and then we find out you
know yeah they got
acquired but they it was before the deal
so to speak when state of decay was made
so they couldn't have only
so just to see them with a budget i'm in
so salute to that [ __ ] well okay early
pre-production though what do you think
that means you're right
what do you think how long until we see
the k3 for real
honestly i'm going 20 22. it's gonna be
a
while
you don't think 2023 maybe yeah do you
think that
you think with that much time do you
think it could
look significantly better than state of
decay 2. oh maybe approach
approach the level of that 20 20 24
no for real like make that turn this is
my thing right
sometimes i get mad when people say
certain games should just
stay at where they're at and not rise
not rise above their station like right
no station yeah let's do this because
the only reason why random tempering
expectations in that particular title is
terms of
the graphical fidelity shown in the
trailer is because that isn't
the vibe i i had heard you know they may
want to go
like mmo survival kind of thing so if
you're doing that you cannot do
cgi that level you know i'm saying
graphics at that level i would be
shocked hey if they do it you know god
bless
them i know they got the big studio
they're going to new island shot jeff
straightening them dudes
but i just like that one they didn't
give up on it too
it's going to actually have a budget
resources the way it was supposed to be
not just you know a polished up version
of one sort of and we already know the
glitches of the bug so
i never got to get to that ever wow i
do i do yeah whenever you're done or do
you want to say something
about state of the game about the whole
scenario
i don't know what the hell is going on
but it's the most beautiful thing i've
ever seen
[Laughter]
that joke looked crazy to me you know
what i'm saying out of worlds dlc they
could have left that there but i am a
fan of the game
so bias cog was like oh hi
i think with the whole point of that is
they wanted to show all those to show
that the studio is working on a lot of
games
then dust falls are getting clown for
this shot the aids leading them dudes
they clown
red i don't know what it is about the
art style that is it
i think it's the music in the trailer i
don't know
ain't no friends i don't know if the
characters move
but it's something about this game that
i was like i'm kind of interested
you know the lead the lead on it used to
work for um
what you're gonna call it these guys the
the guys the the
the two not the two human guys the um
what's your detroit become human
oh i mean i mean i mean i love you funny
dreams
is something about that game i know
people look at it it's still pictures
the ground i don't care
i know king going in on me no i'm not
i'm not listening to you i wasn't going
to give you this
you didn't give me the problem zero
frames per second zero
at that event i don't care who friend
they belong to
yeah that was a deal that was that was
somebody dance project
yeah that was somebody's like this
that's exactly when i looked and i said
damn it this is it right here this is
the best
yeah you died and you know what it is
this is the part where everybody was
complaining when they hit that low well
okay right now
they did the mess up with the um what's
that game
um um from ninja theory oh he did the
method
with that and then this comes right
after that this is what
disguise yeah i got you you had a part
in the middle like oh no microsoft not
here
that's what you was a little shaky
and then to hear you say yeah i'm
looking forward to go for it
look at the diversity of the lineup that
you got people that's gonna be like me
that's gonna say yo i'm looking forward
to that microsoft thing
i'm just saying james and you're not
gonna play it but your bad phil
dominance is doing it for that group you
gotta respect
it i i do think that's one of the issues
i like right now
yeah i don't care addicts
i got you let me finish up my thing all
right so you got that
bro ran i'm gonna tell you right now and
this is selfish
car uh-huh once destiny 2
was announced beyond light i said 10 out
of 10
game of the show they don't have to show
me nothing else
my favorite game beyond light free
expansions get down and lay down
over here phil phil did it who did that
for you phil did that for me
he listened to me he said he don't cog
like destiny he said no cars betrayed
him for pc
come on home car with this it certainly
seems like uh bungie and
destiny or bungie and microsoft are
getting a little bit cozy
some i don't know you know a little cozy
you know is microsoft like come on back
to us baby we know we know you straight
for a little bit we know you straight
and that's okay you had to experiment
that's perfectly fine for you
broke up she just broke up with come
activision come on back
i said i do think that that can open up
potentially in the future for another
purchase for them buying them
i said this on last word pete parsons
the ceo of
budgie is extremely buddy buddy with
phil spencer
and at the end of the day they play that
we know phil plays destiny all the damn
time you know saying
at the end of the day just look keep our
eyes who knows that's a
big get because to be honest i was going
to say [ __ ] how big is that
not only to being game pads to be in
there plus the new one
not only is that going to drive the
online player base right
now destiny listen on last word podcast
strictly dusty podcast
i've got pc guys and playstation guys
say yo
cog i'm in you know what i'm saying like
i'm jumping i got non-destiny guys like
yo
on game pass i'm in so sign me up teach
me what i've missed
that is a huge because to be honest with
you ran they could have literally just
said
base game destiny 2 on game pass it
wasn't the base game free
though base was free you're right
spinel is free freezing but my entrance
are still costing right not forsaken
not shadow keep which are huge
expansions huge quality expansions
right some of the best in destiny since
taken k so you could have said the base
without those two
and that would have been a fantastic
look this is extra this is given
our new except people understand if
you're not in the destiny community
september expansions are the biggest
reworks of the game
that is literally the best content if
you don't play ted you play in september
that
fall expansion now november which is
convenient that it's launching close to
the series x but i didn't get into that
that's about other
tinfield hat working you know saying but
at the end of the day even if you
don't care about destiny even if you
hate destiny
the fact that that online service game
is
in game pass and i said this on
ainsley's podcast the big cast with king
yesterday
if this opens up future things like
division
like warframe that is huge for these
online service type games and service
games
you you've already just ingratiated and
brewing up this
this is a huge deal it's not just
because i'm a destiny capper
it's literally a youtube so please hear
me when i say that so
that was that i'll finish up real quick
um warhawk warhammer looks like some
for four player joint that look kind of
cool medium look
fire y'all i don't care about medium
you watch that four minute game play ram
of the of the joint off the
yes medium looks great can't wait
to do nothing for me watch the four
minute one that not the one outside
that's the one that they showed
is another one that i got hit with in
the dm and it and it actually explains
the game a whole lot better
right now i know it looks really good i
don't like that it's not 60.
but i do like yeah you can be 60 with
the two reality they doing the two
realities it's
crazy i care not that i'm just a fan but
i like that joint and then the last
thing that nobody's talking about
and i heard it all so i'm shout out to
damn i want to just hear it shout out to
jasmine i love love
too crossfire x in my opinion next to x
marker was the best that
those two were next-gen looking games to
me crossfire x looked
i look crazy you know what i'm saying so
then you got what you call it remedy
doing the um the singing player get a
campaign
the multiplayer i guess is a game pass
or whatever whatever so hopefully it'll
charge too much
but bro i i looked at the showcase i'm
like
selfishly for me i'm i'm good like that
that's just how i was at attic red
finish every morning that's the thing
that's first though yeah quick
because we're really behind we got
something smooth to find out super chat
there will be absolutely no lord king
slander talk
be careful i will read these scriptures
then we have ever born saga with the
finals which had all the complaints
about game pass can be said about
netflix and remind me again how many
subscribers does netflix have
yes and we got best stars find it's
michael with the final super chat really
tired of people throwing shade toward
xbox
the show was great and let's move on
shout out to youtube king
and all the lords i'll get there i'll
take over i'll take it
gotta find out from gaming forte y'all
better leave brap alone
we all know that man flip-flops like a
fish
hashtag all love bread you know what
gaming forte you ain't on or nothing
because he's still gonna get this smoke
we got a two dollar super chat from the
trigger man why is fortnite still behind
the live paywall at 120 a year play it
on playstation
they got a console for you look look man
you want it for free
streaming we do think that needs to come
down but he's right man if you don't
want if you don't want me
to everybody take it down then you can
join
but if you don't like it that way
because a lot of other places that you
could play now those places are
dangerous
king's right choice between netflix and
game pass
some people gonna have to make
sacrifices or you can be like me and buy
three months at a time and we gotta find
all this soup oh this is for you king
because it's chris hart oh
oh what chris heart just read it because
it's behind you
i think kings might just read it because
yeah i can't just read it we got a five
dollar super chat
from uh christopher my guy
what's that credit card slot uh slot
uh series exhibition oh he's he said
he's calling you out
if you pray your rent king says
oh man he has all these checks okay if
you play your ranking
says pay game uh paid game guys first
pocket hashtag watch it yeah yeah
yeah that is true chris but i understand
your fears with game pass and like i
eloquently expressed
earlier basically you feel people can't
maintain this no
i'm just i'm not even going to go deeper
though okay fair enough we got a five
dollar super chat from
short hades i bought a ps4 to play games
like persona 5
and dragon quest 11. xbox is solely
taking away my reasons of owning a
playstation next year
i i did say that in a video i was like
there's a lot of people that
only want to play those type of games
and if they're not on xbox at all
your platform's not even uh you know an
option for them but we'll keep going on
to that
we gotta find our super chat from super
panda give me all the passion projects
every game was someone's passion project
at some point
super chat from the wise old gamer look
xbox trying to be netflix
sony is trying to be pandemont but i
definitely looked at that
whatever man whatever we're gonna keep
it moving both make money why the hate
on tcl my uncles sound like a ccps
cataract
[Music]
respect man i'll do respect my tv is a
tcu but we ain't going in
thank you phil now i don't have to puke
when i switch from pc to xbox
oh more than you know plus i call to
carry over a month ago
okay you're reading the next couple
batch because my voice is gone
hold up wait i got that okay that's it
okay cool cool man
out of control man look this is this is
the main event y'all know what we
solve y'all know what we're here for no
bang bang the pain you know what i'm
saying so it's it's been a very
hot topic over the internet halo
infinite it's a lot of backlash the
memes and the birth of craig my tv
you guys look at my life oh [ __ ] that
tcl oh
right there i can't that's right
i know what it is we this thing has has
taken all the life of its own
you know so uh let's get to it man um
rand we
know how much you love
i do you are the man with the million so
let's get to it man
now that you got a chance to sit on it
what is your feelings
about this whole situation halo infinite
backlash halo infinite oh man
uh huge fan of halo right like i've
reiterated this so many times
it's my favorite franchise i love the
gameplay that they showed honestly
uh i could see myself having a blast
doing like all the
like fighting the brutes and and the and
the elite using all the different
weapons and the gadgets like
i was like looking at that i'm like that
looks like so much
fun to play 100 60 frames
give it to me give it to me non-filmic
cord and i hope he's listening somewhere
shut up with your friends
right so but you know like it did
yeah look you notice the information
cost you
like like i get i'd rather have a game
running at 60
than uh you know if you need to
compromise on the visuals i'm perfectly
okay with that
like the gameplay means more to me and
what it looks like it's just that what
it looked like was
it didn't look like a very polished demo
in regard to visual quality like
textures were missing all over the place
uh popping
everywhere and i'm like thinking to
myself like well okay
it's running on the pc as we found out
later right right that was okay so it's
like
not really showcasing the xbox blocks to
the architecture very well but then
maybe it wasn't even using it so
once again kind of a minus to the point
of like showcasing the series x accident
good light
which they're very good showcasing the
series x when it comes to
blog posts not very good showcasing the
series x when it comes to uh
visuals with the games and stuff but
yeah i mean
then then like halo infinite just
becomes a gigantic meme that one still
frame image
of a deadpan brute just kind of just
like looking off in the distance
with no textures on his face
and imagine like that's not what 343
wanted
they essentially the game just become an
absolute
joke to a lot of people but smartly they
impressed them they embraced the me
yes called him craig now everybody's
kind of joking around with it
um do i expect the game to look
better yeah i mean if everything they're
saying is truth and not just pure damage
control right
if it really is an old build you know if
aaron greenberg's come out and said hey
it's no build it'll get better and
better and better and all that stuff
like if that's the truth then
uh when it comes to series x you know
it'll it'll be great
right it'll look good i'm more concerned
with the gameplay myself
um rap is so messy it's so messy and we
got to just read it brad patel super
chat
craig ft tuffy for the win
king may not agree with me but craig is
so adorable yo
yo you see where they got it with with
the guard award
no you got to see when they did you saw
the e.t ones
yo the craig means
look i mean i know like the thing here
is so halo infinite is
essentially an xbox one game at its core
you can tell
you can tell from every angle this was
made for the xbox one
and they are basically trying to upgrade
it for series x
and they essentially make an open world
halo game which is great that's
something i've always wanted
you know from when i first played halo
was like oh cool man
imagine if you could explore the whole
ring right
how could that be right so you're
finally getting that here and of course
xbox one it's it's a it's a dinosaur
it's got those
right i wasn't about to use a bad word
thank you for the lord but it does it
doesn't have the best cpu
right you know like hold up jack i know
yeah and it's got to run
on the xbox one so it's like yeah so i'm
like look 60 frames is great i
understand there's probably compromises
they need to make
but it wasn't the best showing uh
for the game in regards to how it looked
and it was definitely was not a good
showing at all for xbox series x
i mean nothing was even shown on the
system but
as a person who loves halo right like i
can't wait to play this game i want to
learn more about the multiplayer
whenever you know if it's next month or
whether it's
in september i just want more halo
i just i just can't wait to play this
game let me ask you two questions
because you made some good points um
the first point is obviously you did
your first initial reaction was that
look
you still feel that it was halo you you
were enjoying the game
oh yeah yeah i watched it i watched it
on stream on twitch and the stream
looked really good
i rewatched it in 4k right on my tv i'm
on my oled king
when you go inside the store i don't
care what nobody say when you go to get
that big ticket item you go pick up that
big television or whatever the hell
you're going to get
you are proud at that moment absolutely
because you buying it with a purpose
if you want to watch your blu-rays or
you going to play your 4k
games in high fidelity because you
brought a pro
and you want to see the most out of your
playstation and you're not baseline
gaming
um but i love that thank you ram oh my
god
so it looked great man halo i mean the
that that 4k
thing looked a lot better um so
yeah like i'm really excited to play
halo like i know
it's become a joke like you can't really
have a good discussion
anymore about halo because it's just
become just like
rallying point for people who don't like
xbox who
don't like halo who are never going to
buy an xbox or we're never going to play
halo
suddenly have all this s
all this stuff to say about x i love it
like all these people who don't give to
who
rat's asses about about halo or xbox
suddenly have the most to say about it
on social media it's it's always so
funny to me i feel you
you know what i think you know what i
think okay
i just i think a lot of people are
attacking halo infinite
like excessive because let's be real you
could attack
you could attack xbox high court but you
could never really attack halo
crazy and i feel like a lot of xbox
haters
they got that chance they're like yo
we can attack halo so so they're all
coming at it like
they're coming everywhere like they make
the me's
because they know that this might not
happen again
you're funny let me ask red this is what
i wanted to ask because i know you're
going at it i know where you're going
but what is in fairness and fairness now
you know for mumps we've heard the most
powerful yeah
you could stop right there brother they
did not show it whatsoever and they have
not shown it
that's on them teraflops we have the
most powerful console i haven't seen it
yet in
in action i got a reason for that
oh i mean there's probably plenty of
reasons no no i got a reason for this
one particular i mean because there's
this one particular game in the topic
that we're going to talk about
because i saw the most powerful console
in the world when i saw forza
so um
it's really good but yeah i mean you
know they talk like you did not see that
in front of this game and you could i've
seen people say halo 5 looks better
mm-hmm
is a linear game yeah on the x it
probably does look better so it probably
does
what about these two factors though in
reference to
one now it's it's supposedly open world
right it's got
confirmation with basically yeah but
overall and the fact that um
besides what it was two quick questions
it was the overall joint
not the 60 frames joint but i'll get to
the other play but let's start with the
living world's thought like the
the 10-year thing destiny thing the
10-year year the 10-year plan that was
one but it was another question i'll get
it it'll come back to me but
i answered that question first it
referenced to that do we want me to
answer the open world thing
yeah like because of the open world
aspect do you have any fear
in reference to this affecting the
quality of game that whole
thing i mean i guess
it really depends how open and like are
we talking
like ubisoft levels of openness here
where it's like some of the missions are
just
dumb you know and they're just like time
fillers
if that's the case well then no that's
not what i want i remember the world
okay go ahead the second part was a
reference to
the fact that it's a cross-generational
game
that we are not getting like almost a
hell back right remember that was a big
thing like a lot of people like yo i
don't want it on the old joint do we
want to see
infinite mass do you think because the
baseline
xbox one it still has to come for that
the whole game design argument right
it's
in defense to the game design lords
these this is some of the stuff that
they were talking about they like see
so you see it on twitter like this by
the way
i mean no you know what yeah you was on
that side you was on inside facts
i've i've always said i mean i've
personally said i don't really talk
about the tech stuff
very much on my channel because i just
don't know about it right i rather talk
about legend
i talk about like what microsoft's doing
and what the games that i'm looking
forward to and are
and news and whatever um yeah i mean i
don't
like they're building the game for the
xbox one uh yeah i think it's probably
couldn't it's not it's not gonna be
what it could be if it was only made on
series x my thing has always been like
people have said lockhart will hold back
xbox series x and i always said no
that's not the case like lockhart is not
going to hold back series x because it
wasn't designed to it's designed to
basically run the same game
at a quarter of the resolution right but
xbox one if you're gonna have the same
game
and it's it if it was two separate
products like forza horizon 2 was
where it was like playground did forza
rise and two and then someone else did
forza horizon 2 and there were separate
products
then that would be a different story or
like shadow of mordor if you remember
like uh there was the nemesis system
wasn't in the 360 version yeah it was in
the xbox one version
that would be a different story like if
halo infinite was like two different
products
made by two different teams but it's not
like because they keep on saying smart
delivery so it's just one product right
uh so yeah
it's probably built around the xbox one
i mean the game has been in development
for five years they only got dev kits
first party like less than a year ago
right so like
it is an xbox one game uh they didn't
even show it running on the series x
so what we're gonna get out of it is an
xbox one game that's gonna have features
that xbox series x gives you uh the 4k
resolution the 60 frames
the better draw distance the better
textures which weren't on display
uh the faster loading uh all that type
of stuff but yeah at its core it's an
xbox one game now
um i just hope the open world isn't like
filler stuff or it's just a bunch of
like oh we got it like oh missions over
here where you go rescue some
marines and it's you know it's kind of
just filler stuff like i don't really
want that
yesterday ten year plan well the ten
year i'm not i'm not against the 10-year
plan because i understand
that usually is good it's good for like
multiplayer right
you look at like the most popular games
now they're all platforms
overwatch fortnite apex legends correct
uh call even call of duty with warzone
like they're all platforms to a certain
degree
and you know people love it when you can
keep on playing the game and stuff
are added all the time like new
cosmetics new modes new maps
if that's their plan that's great my
concern is about the single player like
and i know they said it like this this
game has a beginning middle and end
and great if it does 100 like if the
story is great and it doesn't have that
beginning middle and end
then i'm cool with it and if the living
plan if the living platform means a year
from now
we'll get like a destiny style expansion
to the campaign that adds like five
hours of like here's chief's next
adventure on another part of the ring
where
he needs to go eradicate the flood or
something right that'd be cool
and jazz explained it on our podcast
we're like think of halo infinite as
basically the master chief collection
where like one day something new is just
added emerging another
world right yeah yeah so i guess it all
it really depends like
how it comes out is the campaign
complete right and is the multiplayer
fully featured
and if those are the cases then i don't
really have a problem with uh
a platform that evolves over time
um so those are my thoughts on that fair
enough we got to get addicted but
how many super traps have we missed so
we have uh well did we get the
they uh perhaps two dollar super chat
they had right they had a craig meme
passing the blunt
yes out of control
then we have gamers play with the file
super chat they switch from unreal
engine 4 to slip space engine to take
advantage of our dna 2 features
early build delayed by pandemic
unfortunate but true
okay then we have the wise old gamer
with two super chat craig slap the bug
snacks out your mouth
and we have get to the point already
with the final super chat i'm waiting
for the game of the year craig versus
buck snacks battle of the century
ready for it you know
just for something really quick i just
want to say please all the xbox fans who
are out there
posting stuff about bug snacks non-stop
you can't get upset about uh about craig
being post enough
so i enjoyed the bug snacks memes and
stuff like that and i'm enjoying the
craigmings because they're funny they're
funny right solutions
super chat talk about the medium dual
realities at the same time yeah
facts fantastic uh especially when it
comes to like puzzle solving gameplay
[Music]
yeah like how that expands game play i
definitely like that oh actually we
missed the wise old gamer with the two
dollars over chat
sony gave buck snacks phil hold my beard
who did that
oh we caught up that's it then we got
slo-mo and no it's good
all right cool i had to get your point
there you were the reason get your ball
off
the point let's get it my new thing is
my new thing is
when you guys say something i want to
say something to you i put it in a
notepad oh
my god
why do people try so hard to justify
crap to people who have different
preferences
in games sometimes it's funny but mostly
it's pointless
opinions
like people like people send me other
people's opinions like i
give up i just want to hear you
i remember you that's like what do i
care if someone so
liked or didn't like the show i don't
know he said he ain't like it
and i'm sending you the information so
yeah
time time you're right correct wait
let's get this one more super chat
oh jb gamer 5. my problem is that
microsoft doesn't need to have
their premiere franchise reduced to this
delay the game if needed but
get ray tracing in their facts i'm
getting more now
that bothered me that bothers me i ain't
going front shout out to you jd
addict what bothers you
after launching yeah like you can't be
published right after launch
yeah they said they did yeah and i'm
like i mean if it traces if the game
needs to be delayed it needs to be
delayed
right if the if well they already shot
down about the multiplayer right
like but if they're yeah if the
multiplayer wasn't going to be there
100 percent that game needed to be
delayed until it was ready if the
campaign's not finished it needs to be
delayed you can't launch halo in a split
package that needs to come out
with the fully fledged campaign fully
fledged multiplayer
could you delay the release of forge
sure you you could
right um how long has this game been in
development
five years five years so we got five
years on this
is this ambition is this project too
ambitious for three four three
i don't know i mean only time will tell
the fact that it had to be moved over
from an xbox one game right now
i think the problem was when they had to
scrap the unreal engine 4 engine
and um and and slipped over to the slip
space
now uh i see the problems
in the game right and watching digital
foundry because i do not make games guys
right i don't make games i play games i
enjoy games now when i saw halo i saw
uh 60 frames per second 4k i'm like this
is it right here i'm
all about this everything that was there
if you watched the
show i was all in and i'm still online i
did that craig's
i yo when i saw craig i thought craig
was the last dude
with his face and i said that why they
just stripped all the textures
off of this man's face but then when i
saw who craig
actually looked oh wow
so but i'm watching the game and i'm
seeing the concept
now a lot of times is okay they're going
to get
they're going to get this work you're
going to get the work and
as running on the dev kit okay you're
going to get this work there's no ray
tracing you're going to get this word
but i think that game was representative
right
of an xbox one x right
and not a series x okay you understand
and
i i honestly believe that that's what
they were pushing like this is what
you're gonna play
and then we're gonna wow you with the
series x stuff because if you don't have
ray tracing and ray tracing is a staple
in the series x
right why the hell are you showing it at
the end correct and at the end of the
day i gotta get out of because you've
been waiting patiently
at the end of the day my only thing is
that there's that expression though
you've only got
one chance you know that you don't have
a second chance to make a first
impression
great and i don't know whose fault it is
but enough about me time on me addict
you've been waiting basically what do
you think about this whole hail infinite
thing man
all right so i i do have something that
i i didn't get to say the last time
uh i i do want to print out a little
like
contradictory that i see in the
community now back
when they said that they were going to
when people
kept misquoting phil and they were
acting like they were never going to
abandon the original consoles
did people constantly say you know what
this is bull
i want next-gen experience correct i
want next-gen experiences
i hate that this is going on now why is
everyone complaining that there's
next-gen experiences because they like
to complain about x-box
it was one of those people selfishly
yeah i'm getting the series x day one
you better be making me games only on
series x i've said that
repeatedly you have you have an attic
you have as well you guys have stood on
that
okay i don't care about other people
why do i care what cognito and king want
i'm they're not buying my games i'm
playing my games
cause then i i i understand that the the
decision right there
that you said it's like i understand the
decision but ran selfish
yes as gamers inherently we are facts
continued
all right so my next point uh is now
let's
say that this is the reason this game is
textureless and there's a lot of
uh you know issues let's just be real
let's be a hundred
like if they did that and they
downgraded the quality of what the
graphics look like to make this game 60
frames
you know people keep saying they want 60
frank games would they be willing
would
if you watch digital foundry this the
video goes up this morning
yes it has a ton of texture the
difference with this halo
is that it uses real lighting source
right right now without the ray tracing
it doesn't give that speculative
i'm going by what he said oh you're
right he said that there's an error in
the lighting
that they gotta correct yeah they they
digital footage went in
yeah you're right and he explained that
it it has the textures everything is
there but the angle of the light
in certain shadows is not going to come
off and it's going to come off flat
right no he didn't say it
because when i saw it i was like oh
they're going back to the basics
all right so that was my next one my
next one is
i was talking about this a little bit
cognito earlier uh yesterday
i feel like i don't know maybe this is
just me like
i've never seen a company grab a meme
like that
and go with it yes like i've seen it
low-key
the last time i've seen stuff this
clowning to this degree
was like massive mass effect andromeda
and
they stayed away from that with
attention like the fact that 343 is
coming out and asking for me
send me your credit it kind of makes me
feel like they knew this was going to be
an issue but it's already fixed and they
don't care
because they know the real products
going to be you know not
not necessarily what people think but
they know it's not going to be to this
degree that we saw in this demo would
you guys think that
because to me they were a little bit too
embracing with this yeah i mean
you want them to do that you want them
to get in front of it you know i answer
real quick you know it's one of those
situations where
look you're going to get clown like rand
said do you think initially the studio
wants this type of negativity towards
their flagship game no
but what can you do so if you get in
front of you own it that's the best
thing and then you they've got
work to do they've got time i think if
you ignore it it ends up being worse
yes yes like i think i think they
basically kind of
uh put the fire out by embracing it and
giving a name and like we're we're in on
the joke instead of
us laughing at like i think they flipped
it like
where the original thing was everybody
was like we're laughing at halo infinite
because of just how this character
looked but when
343 smartly were like oh it's that craig
and i want to learn more about him
i think it then became like more about
more less about
laughing and halo infinite and more just
laughing about the meme and the
the things that people create with it
right pretty much what you're saying is
they're like look we don't want them
talking about hey well we want to
talking about crack
so instead of being part of everything
we're going to give them
a person to clown up but look like this
when you talk about craig and the people
are mement about it it's all halo
infinite so what do you got on the brain
halo infinite right so i mean like look
they put out
you see that one screenshot 343 put out
officially where everybody's just kind
of standing super still
yes from the side with the brutes
standing there just not looking like a
very good screenshot
and you're just you're sitting there
like why did 343 put that out
officially because it's i mean it kind
of looks like saab right now look saab's
doing the craig
he's got that deadpan face right now
like you got the craig face
let's get out of your fishing balls and
get something and then you know
i only have two more points like yeah
the the thing that at the end of the day
it's like it's like i said
back in the day you know when we
initially argued that this like you
could scale everything but some things
just aren't scalable
like when you when you're making an xbox
one game and you're upscaling it to an
xbox series x
it's not going to improve the series x
experience
it might improve it in some features but
it's not going to prove the
the core the foundation the game was
built on because it wasn't built on a
series
it was built on an xbox one and at the
end of the day
you can't really expect a next-gen
experience from an xbox one game
and then the biggest thing that i want
to say is
how many years right and ryan you you
can attest for this
how many people have you said i'm tired
of 343
going away from the halo way i want a
halo experience i want combat
to be the way it was how many times you
said you heard that right a lot
now the gameplay seemed you couldn't get
more halo light
like i understand people being upset
with the textures and stuff and the way
the game looked
but how is it that i saw more about that
than
the thing that people have been
complaining the most about because i
think
i think it comes down to 12 teraflops
the world's most powerful console
and then the game shows up and as
as i'm quoting addict here textureless
and i think that's what i think people
were like
okay blow me away show me what you got
series zach
and what you got was halo on the pc that
was the build from
apparently january who knows but let me
ask you because a lot of people here
here's the they don't read this
this is a counterpoint that i i don't
agree with but i just want to put it out
there people are saying
because they are disappointed and they
don't like it
that because if we like the gameplay
we are damaging damage controlling yeah
for those people
we need to be not liking it
and and and upset now i'm with them on
graphical fidelity
right i'm just going to sure my heart's
going to be quick you know i'm saying
i'm with them on graphical fidelity
but at the end of the day it's like yo
when they do it if you're
again a classic halo i come from halo
combat evolved
when the joint came down and i saw the
ring the vegetation
and i'm in i'm smiling ear when i'm
watching if you hear us on the live
reaction
i'm like this is the vintage halo that i
grew up on and he jumps in the warthog
you're doing the weapons you're doing
the grappling hook from a pure gameplay
standpoint and the grass disappears
all right true and in the pop-up
first first thing i noticed was the
grass disappeared i'm like what is going
on
if you look at the reaction i didn't
even notice any of it
like you know what i started noticing
when you grapple hooked up to that
that's when i started noticing yo this
look a little spooky because when you
look at that right when you're looking
at the crates
right it it it looks like clay it
doesn't look like a crate it looks like
you know the grab hook opens up so many
cool things grappled towards the enemy
grapple up to areas like it happens it
opens up a lot of combat scenarios
right he actually made a good point
because he
like he he felt a little annoyed by the
grappling hook because
technically your armor weighs like a ton
and he's like
you shouldn't have to even melee people
if you're like ascending to them that
fast
and he's like if you want to get real
tactical how is the grappling hook going
to move a ton that fast towards it but
i'm like
you know what you got a little point
there like games video games man but
look i get it i make it quick um
like i said that part the only way i did
notice it is when he went up the
elevator
and i look in the background at skybox i
was like oh i saw a little rain i saw
that five minutes and probably
what's going on over there i was like oh
but other than that you know what i'm
saying
look if you don't like it and you and
you say to yours
i feel anybody i will never get mad at
anybody who says yo
that joint don't look next gen that
joint don't look like 12 teraflops
that i ain't sold fam i 100
if that's you no doubt i ain't arguing
with you bro
i i'm not trying to sell you i'm just
saying for me
as a classic halo fan i felt there was a
lot of homages
in what they were doing right was it the
best graphic fidelity to know but i
still enjoyed what i was i still gonna
get it i liked it
so that's just where i'm at with it you
know i'm saying i want to get solved and
king and
i want to move it on a little bit in
reference to this whole infinite thing
all right we have a bunch of super chat
stuff yeah you got uh brad with the two
dollar super chat car
ghost is fire can't stop playing cherry
blossoms
yeah born center bourne center with the
five hours of the chat does xbox deserve
more
excuses after this event this was their
chance to show out and they did not
right all right yeah fair enough
you have every right to be disappointed
if you're not feeling it continue hold
on and jump me
we got the wise old gamer with the final
chat attic be careful i wouldn't buy
xbox series x
at launch if i were you i don't want
your tcl to blow up in your house
my brother look man if you're that
concerned about my well-being man you
could help my
paypal hit up his key for that key leg
and we have biener with the five dollar
super chat no ray tracing
mid spec pc old bill microsoft basically
sent uh send d pick oh wow
yes you know i could look better but you
still set that soft stuff
wow wow that's crazy
yeah moving on let's see what you got on
the brain right now
clearly i don't know
um like i said during the stream
everything about the gameplay screamed
halo to me in a way that i that i
enjoyed the fact that
it seems like the game is going open
world semi-open world i love that take
damage control
i didn't like it beyond that beyond that
just looking at and i'm not going to go
into the alex battaglia breakdown i'm
not going to go into that
i saw with my own two eyes aesthetically
was not pleasing to me
right and what bothered me about that
is when you look at and i'm not going to
compare it to other first person i'm not
going to compare it to doom because doom
is sort of a
a sort of an on rails type of shooter
this is not this it's not an open world
so
if i'm going to compare this game to
other open worlds i'm going to compare
it to
horizon zero dawn i'm going to compare
it to goes to sushima
even witcher red dead 2 the fidelity
of the world was not where i wanted it
to be and it's just like well
i get going back to the core of halo but
the core of halo to me is the game play
and that was there
i don't need to feel the same way that i
felt when i stepped off of that pelican
and in when i originally played halo
combat of all keep your og artistic
expression to yourself
i was i wanted to come out of that
pelican and see
blades of grass and see trees that
didn't look like they were drawn by bob
ross oh i don't want to stand
wow damn i want to see that like and
that
what bothered me about that right is the
fact that
this is your pillar showcase
and and again what i want i want halo to
stand shoulder to the shoulder with the
very best
and and as a halo fan
besides the gameplay part which seems
like it's fine and if you look at 343's
track record with halo right
between the two original games that they
made they've made one good halo game
right they've made
one that had a campaign that i i liked
right which was four
um the multiplayer not so much and then
five multiplayer they got that
perfectly right and i didn't like the
campaign they showed they can make good
halo
right i just don't i feel like the
aesthetic choice that they made
is no no no no no i didn't need that i
don't need the homage i don't need the
homage look
i didn't need that get your old school
mixtape give me the homage gameplay
i'm good right i i wanted it to look
like the next
hot thing and it doesn't look at least
at this point doesn't look like that and
that disappointment because like
to me is again it's it's it's about halo
and what halo represents
to xbox okay and it it it didn't
it didn't show the way i wanted it to
show okay again
as as a whole yeah the fact that it's
going in the game pass
the fact that damage controller solves
like quality of the gamepad
controller well it is no no no no about
the quality and game pass
um again and the fact that it feels like
it's going to be a platform
right and then they're going to grow
that i don't want it again
if they start giving me weapon quests
and stuff like that
you don't want your destiny in your halo
you know what you're expecting
no no no don't destin the guy whatever
you want why you don't want your exotics
in the new patch
none of that none of that if you give me
new content that is actually
new story content i'm in all the ways
if you tell me i have to go get this and
this this weapon and then i gotta
upgrade and then i'm handling it playing
i'm done give me a ten year plan with
actual story content without all that bs
i'm good
i'm good oh you hate this that's what i
i i hate that part of destiny that's
what i hate fans
and that's it and that's it yes yeah
let's get these super chat so we got our
gamers played with the final super chat
oh playstation xbox is holding things
back for the for the tit for tat tactics
the pr game of chess there is another
event they still have no release date
yet
true but i'm tired of this
wait for tomorrow narrative i feel that
i feel that um
jd gamer with the final super chat
please delay halo and only release it
when finished with ray tracing
and now microsoft and bungie getting
cozy again
back home today imagine that they come
out
that's right you know that's how baby
that's her child yeah that's her job
three four three is the step dad
that's her baby i think even if bungie
was bought they're not
they're not doing it because they didn't
want it they left because then he didn't
want to do halo anymore but i do think
that
i do think that if let's say
hypothetically that microsoft did buy
best uh bungie i think it would be one
of those where
the studios are linked but they're not
linked like they just let their devs
openly go back and forth
after a project's done right to give
them a break from doing one or the other
right now this didn't they say this guy
which is the the
the head like was it not jason or is it
jason rubin the head of um
343 yeah no yeah the one that worked on
halo from the very beginning uh
that's how i ran quickly 343 i'm talking
about bungie bungie oh
you've been you know from the musical
standpoint is marty o'donnell oh now
i've already done a musical
he worked on the director's standpoint
is luke smith luke's
from the ceo standpoint is pete parsons
right so didn't they say
they were already sort of whiteboarding
what was coming next
and it's not destiny you talk about
durian oh yeah you talk about that other
stuff
yeah because you're talking about
destiny's new ip after
uh yeah
yeah supposedly they're making like uh
like an overwatch type of game yeah i
thought it was more like a diablo
oh diablo yeah you're right diablo
diablo i'm sorry
oh really the thing the thing that the
thing i really want quickly i just
remembered
uh halo infinite's music uh done by co
composed by gareth coker uh of ori
orifame so you know the music's gonna be
phenomenal
and what it was like the music was
amazing
in that trailer though
real quick i feel bad for a lot of these
developers this pandemic is really
starting to affect everyone soon a lot
of games like about to get pushed back
uh yeah phil said as much like things
further down the pipeline are probably
gonna get delayed we got the wise old
gamer with the followers which
phil recommends players smoke blades of
grass before they get
they can see halo's blades of garage he
did that for you
wow um we have a cat daddy with the
photo
in the words of king bungie wants that
old thing
back great show thank you that's uh i'm
i want to send out my condolences to uh
cat daddy fast axe
grandfather um sorry brother um you
as soon as i just saw you pop up right
there we bend the knee brother
we know you know the fact that you even
hear we know he's more rest in peace man
recipes
that's that's a sad situation yeah hey i
always hate to hear stuff like that yeah
man he's a good dude man so condolences
to the family
uh we all caught up with super chats off
yeah we'll cut up
okay um king i know you're ready okay
well
um yo that halo was a fire xbox one
x game
that framing that frame right fixed on
that one x
games yo did you see the draw distance
yeah the xbox one yeah x yeah that xbox
one x
is that it's firing on all cylinders my
man
i'm not even gonna lie when i saw it i
was like yo this xbox one x is crazy
this this this is is they really doing
it this is the potential because a lot
of times you know dudes was like yo when
is
you know y'all say i got the most
powerful console but you're never using
the potential you saw it
you saw xbox one x not series x
in full effect because series x got ray
tracing and got a whole bunch of other
stuff going on so i
actually believe that was representative
of what those dudes that cause remember
he was telling you y'all didn't have to
upgrade and this is a game pass show
so this this is for you guys 1x
get this this is you so this is what
you're going to see that little pop-in
that you saw 1x
it was a gay past show prior to the show
sir
well i'm i i like it
i love everything about this because
you dudes that have the xbox one x right
myself included yeah if i choose not to
upgrade
well i will upgrade regardless but if i
choose and you choose not to
what so is representative or what you
will get
all right and that's exactly it now
did they put themselves in a position
where speculation can happen or how come
i'm not seeing the power
of the series x yeah i don't see a
reason for me to upgrade and go forward
well you told you didn't have to
um told you literally if you saw nothing
there
we got game pads get loose
this whole time everything that you saw
isn't getting past get loose if you get
a spirit dance you can play the medium
you can do all this stuff date and date
you are
covered right and that's a good way to
do it but i honestly believe that that
game is indicative of an xbox one
x and nobody wants to come out and say
it i feel that
you know and it looked like an xbox one
x game
and i just want to say yes halo going to
the base
right halo infinite going to the base
for the motor sport
going to place i believe that you're
going to get a gears game that's going
to go to the base
and i believe these games is going to be
the pillar that's inside
game pass those gear games that they're
going to be adding stuff
to that you will be able to um play
different campaign
stuff a building in it
and it's going to grow with you and then
the same studios will be allowed to do
the gears tactics for the horizon
right and whatever halos of the project
like
halo wars and other stuff like that and
those are the um side projects that will
expand from that
so when we see this game
and we're frustrated right with the lack
of textures or
or whatever understand that i honestly
believe
that this was the xbox one x game well
in a sense ryan said what you're saying
is correct it was originally designed
from the s1 but but to to the people can
we
can we bend we might have to can we bend
the knee to the design lords our lords
were saying this day it's like when you
when you and that's another thing right
with that argument
the argument about skatability is kind
of thrown out the window with this
like no that it's not because it was an
arno x
and well no no series x it was on a
regular x so
you saw what you won't get with the axe
now when you or a series that you're
gonna see scalability you're gonna be oh
word i see your difference my man i see
the ring tracing all around and you got
it all
it's all sparkly and stuff right i was
looking for
it's no popping right you see how fast
this stuff is and you're gonna see that
representative of that
now watch when y'all get it y'all gonna
be like yo
dude was right
[Laughter]
he had the other x it switches the x
y'all got it
your ex is wrong got the x's wrong
that's all
yo it's my bad chat the alarms is me i
apologize those notifications will be
it's my instagram's popping up i'm sorry
i will get that fixed for next show
didn't realize y'all heard that thank
you all for telling me
sorry oh you see what you had solved and
then we gotta go for it eric jackson
with the final super chat
we had halo anniversary uh anniversary
ce
why are we reimagining yes i agree also
why do enemies
move exactly the same and why are there
less enemies on screen than in halo 5.
um the open world nature is different
right i get that
um regular x and i but i is another
thing that i forgot to mention during my
bit
is the animations for certain things
like when when i threw a grin
when they threw the grenade on the on
the um on the brute they
flew up out of the and the grenade
blew his face up there was no reaction
he just
like there was no physics reaction he
just fell forward
like but i like the part when when the
brute was well with craig was running
and he shot him in the leg and then he
slowed him forward
yeah i like that forward and then he
just fell forward flat
and that was it no so there's parts
where it looked like it had more than
what it showed
and then there was other parts so there
was just no reaction i'm like wait a
minute you just took a grenade to the
face
like why are you not falling backwards
why are you not
it's this
you know how when y'all go to a
restaurant and it says pardon our
construction
yo it says
he's a handsome you know he's not that
handsome but he's got a good personality
that's what that was that's exactly what
that was
yeah that's craig is like yo you're not
he's not a looker
he's just like he's a good dude though
once the strobe lights come on yeah yeah
exactly that's the late night you have a
cup
couple of drinks and it's lit
and no cat daddy it's not my tinder
popping so stop it it's instagram i
apologize
um your cat is killing me right now uh
before we get the switch alex holding on
to this thought then we hit the super
chat get at it
all right i completely forgot i'm sorry
sorry about that i should have been
quick on that super chat you're gonna
super test simon break with the five
pound super chat
full spencer actually said that they
have another event probably in august
during his interview with uh uh al
justine love king giving tcl that tlc
is absolutely dude we had the wise old
gamer with the fight all the super chat
difference between halo and fable i sell
jordans you want to use your coupon
here's these jumpman for you oh oh you
want that retro
retro 5 get your weight up
look i think everybody pretty much got
their bars off unless ram would have
finished but we got to move on he's
ready to get it together so this whole
halo infinity thing we've beaten it to
the ground
i mean don't the only thing that is time
will tell like
does it will it look better when it
comes out uh you'll know that hey the
truth was it was an early build
and they just showcased uh you know one
that they maybe they just showcased
something they really shouldn't have
right and that'd be a failure on the
marketing but
only time will tell how it's gonna look
and how the series x version will
perform and
you know i would imagine that's not ray
tracing isn't coming at launch because
uh work from home like impact to 343
greatly
yeah and they're probably just focused
on getting the game out
because it's going to come in hot it's
going to come down to the wire i think
it's launching with the console
and they're probably they got everybody
on it yeah yeah i even hear they got
other teams on it
like people from other other xbox
studios working on it
and i don't think i don't think ray
tracing unfortunately king
you know cog sav and attic was
was on the the list of priorities to get
the game shipped out on time it was like
we need to we need to get this game out
yeah and then i think maybe the demo
itself like if that demo really was
from a january build or maybe february
march
and then you know work from work from
home hit right they maybe they didn't
have go
they didn't have time to go back and uh
you know improve
the that demo slice and a significant
way to make it look better because
at that point it was like because like
what i was told when march hit and april
came it was like
they're about to slip into 2021
343 was not equipped to work from home
and build that game
wow and they had to they had to like
bring in other people outsourc like
they basically threw everything at halo
infinite to get it shipped this year so
you might be seeing some of that uh you
know only time will tell like hopefully
when the game comes out
it looks a lot better yeah it's gonna
play smooth we already know that you can
tell from the demo
60 frames i think the grapple hook opens
up a lot of combat
scenarios it looks fun to play um
and it's a complete game like the
multiplayer is completely
uh filled out it's got like all the
different modes 4v4
it's got like uh you know like maybe big
team battle and maybe even another mode
or whatever
and uh then people's concerns will be
like all right you know i was concerned
but hey they nailed it but
amen if it comes out as subpar product
i'll be the first one to say it's a
subpar product
no doubt you know and you know what's
funny
how many how many people
because like i i brought up on uh
another podcast
at the beginning of last of this week i
said look so at the end of the day
is it an excuse of covet yes is it an
excuse anyone wants to hear
no right uh people really have this
mindset
that covet is not hurting development in
the entire industry not just at
microsoft
it's like how many games have been
delayed right
how many like we don't even have a
release i wasn't that ignorant in the
beginning
yeah how how many call of duty you don't
even have a release date
we in july we can't we can't act like
cole but it's not a fact i don't want to
put this
but you're right like we're not going to
act like it's not a factor
it's just the sad reality is
unfortunately you know with xbox's cases
like nobody
wants to kind of hear it because they
want to see because how many times have
they messed up a room
right so you get to the part where how
many times are you gonna cry wolf nobody
cares that the wolf is on your neck for
real this time
you know so it is what it is man when it
comes down to it it's like look like
you know a lot of people you know
slow-mo i'm sure he's still in the chat
you know we i talked to him on scumcast
yesterday and
he i told him i was like look at the end
of the day
they were in a position where they show
something right and they have to show
something right
you know he he might he gave me the
argument that
they could have you know show you okay
let me just ask you guys this question
real quick just give me a yes or no we
want to go into big detail
let's say they didn't have what they
needed righty let's say it took them
another month another month
now let's say at the beginning of the
show they show where the the suit is
being made
right and then after that show
come on september the 5th for a
full-blown gameplay of
and this is their most anticipated
flagship title and that's what i said
if that wasn't going to be the case they
were almost better just
not having a show till august then you
should have the show when it's ready
it's it's like i said i was like at the
end of the day right they had to show
something
yeah i think they could have showed
something better than what they showed
you know they could have showed like
some kind of story trailer to
to get more a little hype that doesn't
necessarily have to show what the game
looks like currently
in that building i don't think they want
to give the tip the hand of the world
but you get you get what i'm saying yeah
little buddy cop thing that they got
going on right now
but i don't think that's indicative of
the story at all i really think that's
just like a small little fraction of
some little banter that they got going
on here
but and because we still have a bunch of
questions that's going on with a lot of
things and i don't i don't think they
want to tip their hand on this
on this game at the end of the day shout
out the bar reader chat at the end of
the day
i agree barry hyped up for bumps
you got to judge it what was what was
shown a lot of people are not impressed
and they got diet work cut out for them
but they got to do what they got to do
to catch up
i mean at the end of the day if you
don't if you don't like what you sell on
halo
don't buy don't buy it that's it it's
not for you fam that's it
for your wallet don't buy halo don't buy
it don't yeah
you know what i what i say is don't
purchase
if you saw something there that you
didn't like don't purchase but if you
have game pass
hey man you're good babe you do it
yeah just because halo infinite didn't
look bad you know it didn't look great
but it didn't look
amazing either it looked like average
like to me
yeah it encouraged exactly
but to me that doesn't take away from
the whole show
and that's what the most thing i'm
annoyed by on twitter is they like that
obviously it's the gym it's the gym of
the show
right but the gym of the show shouldn't
dictate the rest of the show true but
it people are trying to act like this is
a three out of ten show no that i agree
that out here at the lowest i would ever
like really realistically let people go
in my mind is like a seven out of ten
sure it's your opinion but i feel like
they showed what they wanted they showed
what people wanted to show them
it's just halo was disappointing i feel
like look i get it it's just some people
just unfortunately
once they get a sour taste for the
beginning that affects their mind for
the whole
rest of the show they don't want to hear
it look we got to move on i'm going to
skip the game pass i think we
all agree game pass is the best thing
about gaming we've touched on it a
thousand times we don't need to say that
gay bass is the best dealing game if you
don't think so then i don't know
what to tell you it's not for you get
whatever service you like
and super chats and then last topic
which it solves you i believe you
have both we don't have any super shots
okay so we're good all right cool
solve this is your joint and get up out
of here really quickly right what we got
with uh
miles so i i want to congratulate
so first of all i want to congratulate
insomniac and playstation studios
on a graduating summa [ __ ] laude
the microsoft school of verbal
gymnastics
are you going that greatness they they
did me proud they really did
proud when they announced that
spider-man miles morales would have
an optional 4k60 mode
and then said nothing else after that oh
when you know what they meant to say was
we have an optional 4k60 mode
it turns off every feature and every
reason that you actually bought a ps5
oh so we do it we're going to get kill
for this this is hot this is a spicy one
that's what it is all right
clarify we got to clarify for what's
going on
do we know for sure
that spider-man is not 4k 60 combo
are you implying that it's when four no
they're turning up like right now
or what are you implying when you tell
me that the 4k 60 mode
which should be the base right if you're
looking at
what you want out of it right yeah 4k 60
mode it should be the base mode right
when you're telling me that's the
optional mode
then that is your performance mode that
is not your core mode right
right by definition the performance mode
is eliminating something to achieve this
usually
graphical fidelity in terms of frames
right so
exactly so the way they framed it is
like look what we can do
without telling you what they're taking
away from you to do to
achieve this okay so
and it's fine it's fine but once again
is it really yeah we've been talking
we've been talking
both both of these companies
are exemplary at the verbal gymnast
like it's it's it's mind-boggling like
what they do
and to me it's just like look it's great
i
i wanted to see spider-man at 60 frames
per second
that's something that's your wish i'm
gonna get my wish i don't know if i'm
gonna be happy
when i turn it back to the 30 frames per
second in the ray trade whatever the
heck it is
are we confirming that ray trace it is
not you know they turned into there is
no way
there's no way do we have it i can't
even do really
chasing as it is to be honest
if they knew it was going to be able to
do it they would have said it
to be honest with you cognito like if
that was in there
then why didn't they just come out
openly at the beginning and have the 60
frames like
clearly something said we hate it
clearly
clearly something when they were making
that game play
that was that was shown for their event
something made at 30 frames
like it's like i want to ask you guys
do you think that this mode was a direct
response
for the amount of backlash that i got
for not being oh yeah
no turn off the lights absolutely
no this is obviously something they were
planning from the game from the get-go
it's not just a mode they just put in
there because a few people were
complaining on twitter
it wasn't two people it wasn't two
people i said a few people i
it wasn't a few people it was a lot yeah
but to me
i just think it was just a mode that was
always planned and they have a marketing
strategy about how they're d
they're doling out information about the
game and it was just time to be like hey
it's 4k 60 whatever like is it 4k and 60
is it dynamic 4k and 60 is it
like i what doesn't really matter all i
care about that's all
i have left i don't care get it let me
yes it could be
it could have you know ray tracing
disabled whatever i don't care
give me the 60 frames i'll see it
doesn't matter to me like whatever
whatever it takes to get to that point
whatever compromises you have to do
i'll be playing frame wait i'll be your
friend
spiderman i'll
everything he can to get that update and
then oh yeah good at it to you
to me i'm just let me let me let me
pause my music okay
to me when it comes to exactly what went
down
it's not that peop people ask them about
the 30 friends that's not the only thing
people are asking them back then
people ask them there was a lot of
miscommunication that they
verbally confirmed right but it would 30
frame was never it
because it wasn't it wasn't on the table
right
i i i firmly believe that because when
they when it first came out he was like
is this a sequel what is this
they said no this is this is a dlc it's
what the uh what's his name said he
wouldn't break
uh and then you know they they confirmed
that it's not the real game
it's a standalone then they confirmed
they confirmed the comparison to what
it's compared to
but you mean it to tell me they they
confirmed all that they answered
everyone's question
but no one answered the question when it
came to the 30 frame state
like nah i think what happened is they
got all that they're like look
can we realistically put a performance
mode in this before launch
and they're like you think twitter has
something to do with their effects
i think that if we were not acting like
they they didn't get attacked a little
bit
digital foundry you meaning to tell me
that people like ign was writing that it
was 30 frames people like gamespot was
right in its 30 frames digital foundry
was destroying them that it's 30 frames
right but all this misinformation is
going on and then sonic and pr is like
we're going to let that slide well
we don't want that slide we're going to
slide like i agree with you is this
if they knew it was 60 frames per second
right and they knew what the engine was
doing the only thing i will give you
is that it is on them to jump in front
of digital foundry in any media outlet
who is putting out
misinformation on the performance of the
game i will 100
agree with you on that part how where i
side with rando
is that i don't think they necessarily
did a reaction to twitter
but it's it's either it's either the
worst
marketing team you've ever seen who
doesn't jump in front
of stuff and tell you what it is that
that's all it is
and to your point at it the only issue i
have
is gamers can't get mad at us
for asking what does the game
run at what is the length of the game is
it
an expansion is it a full-fledged game
because the issue
i have is i didn't think those were bad
questions but i got attacked on twitter
but said i want to know
what it is because the vibe i initially
thought was this was an expansion dlc
with miles morales were in the game you
know for this
couple of story missions or whatever it
is i did come to find out there's only
five for 10 hour plays but we're gonna
get into that
but about the hours of play but i wanted
to know and i felt it's imperative
on them to tell us you just showed it it
looked phenomenal
at the sony show i'm interested tell me
what it is is it a full-fledged sony uh
you know game why does it have
spider-man 2 miles morales like
they did this it's verbage so this is
marketing and then when the
when the vice president comes out and
says yes it's an expansion
yes it's only a couple hours twitter
can't get mad at us for repeating what
he said and then that guy had to get
corrected
that's all i'm trying to say like it's
it's it is bad messaging it is bad
marketing that that's that's just call
what is we just dragged microsoft
it's this is nothing wrong with
asking questions and demanding from your
favorite just because it's your favorite
they are not absolved from questioning
the memo oh yeah clearly it's it's it's
only right to ask
xbox for demand you can't actually
playstation because that has
been you're asking too much you're not
letting the developers go
remember i'm still asking switch for
voice chat
well at the end of the day you know all
i'm saying is what
i can see right what i saw is then come
out
openly on every other corner when it
comes to miscommunication
but that one they just let slide right
jay barry said
initially said otherwise and everybody
just repeated what they said
same like digital foundry initially said
30 frames per second everybody's just
repeating what the media outlet said so
it's
on insomniac to get in front of that
and tell people how does the vice
president not know what the game's
running at
you don't say like that's on them that's
interdepartmental stuff that they got to
clean up
we can't damage control it just because
it's our favorite that's all i said
look look at some of aaron gerber's
stuff that you know was going on
in major announcement when they were
doing these interviews when someone
asked them a question like that
they said i i don't i'm currently not up
to
up to date what's going on over there
let me reach out and then i'll get back
to you that's what they said like
to me it's like i said i can only go off
what they go
what they told me and guess what the
sauna didn't tell me [ __ ] that's it
that's all like all right get
you already know what i said that is dlc
so they can sit there and say whatever
they want to say that performance mode
be it there be it not i don't care
what did it take off take off the ray
tracer take off the reason why you
showed up
are you picking it up sir oh i'm picking
up a playstation
i'm picking up a playstation just
so i can style on them like yo
you know really i don't even want one
really because i didn't see anything
from this show that made me say oh i'ma
get it
because it was really nothing there
except for
spider-man no you could say i'm fraud no
you're like i don't care
what i'm saying is first of all gran
turismo's not gonna be there
all right ratchet and clinton ain't
gonna be there so uh what do you think
i'm supposed to buy for godfall throw
yourself in the bushes get out of your
mind
so okay so now you already got me in the
door
with uh the dlc right right i got i
gotta pay six hundred dollars for the
with the dlc i gotta get the dlc
because y'all wanna y'all wanna put me
but behind the paywall all right
i'm in with the with the dlc i'm gonna
do my little eight hours
and i'm just doing it to style on you
because i know a lot of you dudes that
be out here capping for sony
i don't even tony that you won't have it
this holiday season
i'm gonna have it this holiday season
just to fight
you what does he say
we know them what
they just talking you know why we used
to hang out in game stores all the time
and the only people that was inside the
game stores that was purchasing was us
so these are the dudes it's like yo
would i get that check that's what
you're saying
that was just hanging around having a
bunch of
opinions and not purchasing anything
[Music]
we used to go in get what we
t harris said did they get in front of
the puddle gate they let that game do
the talking
um according to digital foundry i guess
it wasn't a downgrade it was artistic
change so you know they didn't get in
front of it because they knew
that was true they knew everything was
true about but okay
i'm sorry everyone in this chat that's
like portalgate didn't exist portalguard
definitely existed
and digital foundry said it wasn't a
quote-unquote downgrade it was artistic
change so you know it is what it is
digital foundry
everyone wants to listen to dessert
until it's not their narrative then no
one wants to listen to digital value
you gotta get you listen we're at the
thai bark this is the bark we've made it
all right so super chatter's out of here
so fill eagle with the final super chat
here's some ip shields because i love
games i play games and couldn't care
less who makes them
no doubt then we have brac with the 20
super chat we already know that
definitive version of halo infinite will
be on the pc
30 series baby
nobody cares that you play on pc bra
are we talking about nobody cares bro
are we talking about the playstation
bangers you play too
oh stop it as long as you're in that
ecosystem sit down and put your feet up
okay if brav got everything it's cool
what's up then we have
gamers plate popping his head off the
hole because craig is out here
we have gamers play with the fallout
super chat actually miles morales is 4k
or 60. oh not see i need confirmation
yeah yeah remember that
it's 1440p that's what they see they got
i don't know we need we need we need to
know
1440p 30 frames per second with ray
tracing
all of that your game is 10
twitter is saying 4k 60 combined so it's
gonna be interesting when we get digital
foundry get a hold of it
hopes and dreams with people that ain't
purchasing continue
we have uh doran edwards with the two
dollar super chat neither xbox a
playstation will show a next-gen
experience until 2021.
facts okay what else and we have mariano
pompano
[Music]
medicine for a bad case of resting brute
face
you say the next one because i'm not
trying to pronounce it appreciate the
levity you bring to this
i haven't heard anything about this um
our playstation 4 accessories compatible
with ps5
like xbox love the show lords i don't
think i don't think so
someone like no people tell me a whole
bunch of new tell me that it is that way
but no one has ever linked me in
articles where sony has confirmed that
yeah like i've had a bunch of people
tell me that the accessories are
compatible
but every time i ask for a link they
they go they just change the subject
we're talking about something else so
link that to me on twitter if you have
that i don't know um i guess we'll see
again
marketing messaging we like to know too
so i didn't know so we all caught up sir
yeah we are done all right so we chat we
hit the automotive bonus people
with the most negative mostly negative
reception by halo infinite by gamers
how do you feel who do you feel is most
to blame for its poor showing at the
xbox games
showcase the choices are a three
four three they have had enough chances
ruining master that ain't it chief
v xbox one cross gen
being forced to develop on old hardware
makes
infinite looks last gen c
marketing bad messaging and way
over hyped halo infinite or
d craig the grunt y'all need to stop
bullying bobby's and leave him alone
shout out to all the people in the chat
shout out
to red outdoor the man with the million
been so long to have him back it's
always an absolute pleasure brother
and real quick you know we got 327
people hit that like button
before we before we
man i love you in the realm man where
can the five people find you what you
got going on sir it was great it was
great being back on the show
uh it's it's always it's always a fun
time with you guys
thank you for not making a four hours we
went from four to three we
it's an improvement thank you man thank
you
um yeah if you want to you know check
out more content youtube channel
youtube.com slash randallthorn19
uh podcast youtube videos all that good
stuff
the beach is going to see what's going
to be happening soon you know sony's got
to stay to play coming up soon
here they might announce a new launch
title that
that's what i heard yeah but it could be
you know but uh xbox gonna show and
stuff in august maybe
maybe king will get that demonstration
of just those 12 teraflops finally
you know maybe you know
you know are we going to react to that
state of place potential potential
perfect dark reveal-ish dark-ish
aren't you in the same chats that i'm in
no i'm
actually i don't think i am but i don't
see nothing so
i'll be in the background i'm like
that's nobody i'm not in a lot of group
dams i'm in two
uh but uh yeah none with you
unfortunately
yeah uh but yeah uh it was great being
on here
uh hit the like button on your way out
guys
make sure you subscribe to these great
gentlemen appreciate it one of the best
podcasts out here on youtube
thank you brother you're coming forward
you've got 16 hates today they agree
there's a lot coming from your brother
now those are all those tc i love
you oh
again xbox 2 is a stellar i bet you guys
are regular listen for me probably one
of my favorites and um it's always good
to have you guys in
i try i know you're making your world
tour so i don't try to abuse my ram
powers but it's always good
comes down from tomorrow tomorrow got
another pocket everybody just came at me
it was just like we need you oh my god
raising all these podcasts around here
this week bro
you bring you bring great perspective
and we love what you do so continue
doing that on brother man much love much
love for the random daughter
and play play more pokemon play more
pokemon play more destiny game pass
being you we
i want some hashtag tcl gang
yes shout out to adam
thank you for the uh the improvement on
certain things i really appreciate
great perspective as always where can i
find people finding you got your videos
out here moving bro so
we're gonna find five what you got going
on you can find me on twitter
lord addict iop you can find me on
youtube at gaming addict i'm gonna have
probably have a video
tomorrow about my thoughts on halo
infinite i i i literally did like two
hours of research
last night on stuff i'm definitely most
of that's not gonna be on the video but
you know we won't go into that
but you know uh you can you could
definitely find me
next week having my mic muted
um you know i do want to ask the
question are we going to react to that
or not
reacted to what so to the state of the
play thing oh yeah
yeah yeah if they if they say shot we
got to see what's going on you can find
me reactions to that laughing
no no no and you're oh shout out to brad
with the two hours of chat according to
insight insomniac
performance is 60 frames per second at
4k yeah all right
that's what we want to see we love that
we love them they don't do it
oh
you know microsoft say it's going to be
better we can't take those words
regardless but i'm solving the five
people find you we made three hours come
on man you gotta be proud
a big shout out to rampa coming through
always a pleasure to have him yes you
know
you can find me i'm about to head out to
work that's what i'm gonna do
um playing goes to sushi meal playing
carrying is absolutely fantastic if you
have not played that game play
carrion it is hilarious it is it is such
a power trip this is it's not even funny
you already know and the king of game
pass himself
shut your tcl mouth lord
what's good i'll say we're going to pop
your fight with you guys
oh yo you know what i love a lot of love
because if you listen to rand talk
people going at you you just you know
what we know it
so it's only i'm not telling you it's
only three content creators that i watch
i watch and okay i'm not saying podcasts
i'm talking about content creators that
i watch because
these guys are wizards with what they do
and they they're my powerful three likes
to my infinity stones so
it's ran it
it's not in any order but i'm telling
you i'll be telling rand sometimes i
just slide in this damn like you're
hitting out the part baby
you're on fire baby you know you know
or whatever so i do appreciate you and i
do appreciate you coming on thank you so
much brother
always bring that balance perspective
and i love the fact that you had
that old leg
that's what it is thanks thanks for the
kind words brother it's always fantastic
um guys go check out uh kos time i was
just like uh hitting all the boots
because
this week we were doing reaction shows
we was going on shows we was
doing all this stuff i didn't get a
chance to promo anything
uh and i and i just promote that stuff
now please go to lawsongaming.net to
make sure that you can get all the
up-to-date information on anything that
you
do or don't know yet we got it there
also make sure you go and watch the last
word with law cognito and ibontes
they are having some of the best
destiny players streamers
uh superior content creators they have
one person
that two man's a raid yes
that was outstanding when i was watching
this stuff it was always
yeah cog was in real form because of the
xbox showcase and
[Music]
i'm recruiting i'm recruiting i just
need solving rain and i'm i'm good
oh no no excuse me we only got like six
minutes okay
okay anything else sir all right good
good you already know it it was being
kind of yo again ran in the building is
always a pleasure we're trying to
get him more i know he's a popular man
but uh we won't wait a year or whatever
how long we'd be waiting to get him
just for xbox big shows and stuff we'll
get rambo but yeah slew to the chat you
always love yeah it was love man mad fun
that's pretty much all i got we got all
dance we got the super chats everything
is good on that and
we're good all right everybody
certified yo they stupid everybody look
man
enjoy your sunday we invited we'll see
you guys next week
hi i'm laura king david of iron lords
podcast
and we're bringing to you an exciting
new giveaway
this giveaway is like none other we'll
be giving away
a xbox series x that's right
you heard me right the brand new console
launching from microsoft this year
well this is how you're able to be
part of that giveaway there's two ways
to get your name thrown in the hat
for the raffle one become a member
of the realm that's hit that join button
and hit it hit that joy
button you hit that join button down at
the bottom
and you can become a member and also
another way is by becoming a patreon
member
so you can be part of the realm as well
now this is brought to you by cat daddy
fat stacks
a member and lord of the realm
a very generous person that's in
our community and this community
is beautiful so remember
you can have one entry by hitting that
join button
and becoming a member of the realm and
also you can have another entry
by being a patreon now you said king
what if i'm a member of both well your
name gets thrown in the hat two times
so please like follow and subscribe
join or become a patreon member
or become both and your name
is in the hat to get that
xbox series x
that's the who did that for you
sweepstakes
this is wonderful this is something that
i'm sure
that you will enjoy oh
man